it's
all in mirror
[Music]
guys i don't know how to tell you this
will started the clock
and the recording at the same time so we
know exactly how long this this going to
be
he finally after a year and a half
realized that he would not be able to
work for nasa
if you don't coordinate things
that's right dropping bombs like flex um
that was will who dropped that um
bianca yes uh
hi hi um let's do
and i have an update on last week what
episode
it's not much of an update i talked to
keane and thompson keenan thompson
who was uh a tuesday listener oh my god
keenan is a little kid and he's a
tuesday list he's not just a listener
he's a two student a tuesday listener
the highest level
top deer yeah feeler uh
and he
they shot paco delicious they filmed it
that's even they filmed so delicious
here's what's great about it too racist
they had to reshoot it as
prs cargo so it you know why it was my
idea because it was two races
yeah it was too racist for the 90s which
is really saying something but it's for
kids so it was
so they had to tamp it down i can't
believe they just
jacked your [ __ ] yeah he keen also keena
did not know and i
couldn't remember if i told him or not
you know what [ __ ] it
let's call his phone oh my god let's go
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] it i love kanan um
i kind of just told his whole story but
i'm going to hit record etcetera it said
i'm going to do it
i'm going to do it all right and let's
just pretend we didn't hear it we're
going to
we want it from the horses the keenan's
mouth
we got to use it looks like he's not
going to pick up wait we might
thought he was tuesday listener damn
keenan
damn let me just say if he doesn't pick
up i never liked him
down with kaden
95. damn
[ __ ] i love o'neill just our
podcast is turning daniel
i'm pushing his famous friends be like
remember that time you [ __ ] your pants
yeah
tell the audience
[Music]
yeah uh like kaluya scared the [ __ ] out
of me by the way
okay [ __ ] hold on you guys you guys i'm
not ready
all right look i'm trying to i'm trying
to get you on i'm trying to blow you up
on this podcast
right now i mean i i described you as a
tuesday listener
um you goddamn right um
all right hold on bianca wants to say hi
cause she didn't know
stop it where are you are you
underground
oh yeah we're on set right now oh okay
excuse me
we're we're here for a hot scoop neil i
wanted to
i wanted you to tell the the prs cargo
journey yeah man play this group music
scoop scoop that scoop
tell me the story no you tell me so what
so you didn't know
about that i came up with pierre yeah i
was listening to the pot
i mean i saw the clip on instagram and
then i couldn't believe that you hadn't
told me that story
how could you never have told me that
you number one
paco delicious was your idea and then
you
were like semi okay with dan just
what am i going to do one of i'm like
19.
yeah that is wild i was exactly one of
my most beloved joints
well what are you talking about well
keenan it's
it's one of we we did that that was us
together you didn't know that was my
that i was carrying you the entire time
there was one set of footprints
the whole time all my best stuff comes
from neil you heard it here
um all right all right god bless peace
man y'all keep doing that thing i love
you
bye okay
[Music]
keenan is the funny thing is we got a
text from seth in the middle of that
that maybe i'm recording
oh so let's stop down
we have to hold on intermission okay we
just paused the
so keenan just said that he confirmed
pogo delicious
um he's a tuesday listener and
i just paused the podcast because
uh eddie murphy now it'll be last night
but eddie murphy was
on seth myers last night
i told seth 15 years ago charlie
murphy told me that the that
john witherspoon and paul mooney
were once gonna beat up eddie murphy
and charlie looked at him like
like what the [ __ ] you talking about and
eddie said yeah charlie they weren't
always old
it's just okay so i've known that story
15 years
last year i saw eddie and i made him
tell me the story
he told the story it's [ __ ] hilarious
he was doing seth tonight seth said
what should i ask him i said ask him
about that i don't and that's like
does he tell the story i was like i
don't know
just say that you'll cut it out if right
and
eddie told the story so seth just sent
us the footage before it's bleeped
and so you're not going to hear anymore
if you say the n word as paul mooney
which is the funniest part of the story
which i'm sorry to say is very
very funny
uh but he does a john witherspoon and
paul money impression
and one of the greatest joys of my life
is
making the darkness brothers
charlie and eddie right stories
about their lives because they're both
they're charlie was insane
eddie still remains insane and their
lives are [ __ ]
and the way they tell stories is so
funny that that clip like
on seth and if you didn't watch it i
guess it would be last night
it'll be on youtube by the time this
airs
it's the funniest that's one of the
funniest i have heard so many stories
working at the comedy store yes
so many stories from insane crazy yes
could ruin people's like everything
hilarious
that is one of the greatest stories i've
heard yes it's so
[ __ ] funny because what eddie does is
so wrong
right the reason they want to fight him
is correct correct
and then mooney threatening to shoot him
even mooney was going to shoot john
landis and eddie murphy
before 48 hours is the that's what
it's just so funny mooney was gonna
shoot in the parking lot of the comedy
store
in 1982 or 81
paul mooney was going to murder eddie
murphy
and john landis before they did come to
america
trading places or 48 hours uh
yeah if the conversator doesn't play
that clip it's just so good
i know the sad thing is what it's not in
the documentary
it just should that is like that's the
[ __ ] then the thing with the documentary
is i don't think people
knew who was doing it
it is very if you don't yeah he's not
gonna be able to get in touch with but
also
i think they did a good job but there
are a lot of these like little stories
yeah that are a part of like like comedy
clubs
yeah that you got a lot but then these
ones just
fell through the cracks that's what i
was talking about when we talked about
the documentary is the [ __ ]
the little rivalries yeah that don't
like that's not part of a narrative
that's not part of a larger narrative
you can't make a thing about it it's
about brotherhood it's just about like
[ __ ] you and witherspoon told me
he was waiting on a coke dealer
because uh
uh he was waiting on a coat he needed
money from the spot
to get to buy cocaine so eddie runs the
lights
mooney had to wait an extra hour for his
cocaine
his serving of cocaine that's what he
told me
with john witherspoon not i don't know
if i said money witherspoon
was waiting on his cocaine dealer um
yeah you don't have to coordinate
cocaine with his nostrils
i if i was doing the comedy store
documentary i would just i would go and
you know what we can do we can i don't
know if we can put the clip
in this why not because it's intellect
it's
nbc's intellectual property well they'll
be like you got to take that down yeah
and we don't want any trouble can we put
the audio
no i don't think so well whatever watch
it
go we'll link to it i'm if i was like
the the most amazing
hilarious stories i've ever heard
obviously working there you get them but
on mitzi's funeral all those people all
those old communities had the funniest
stories that will never live beyond
their kind of
generation you know maybe a little bit
here and there
but like i'm like go hit up look they're
all on the wall
all the people you need over on the wall
like i know they hit up current people
in like rising stars
it's hard to get
eddie it's hard to get dave it's just
hard to get it's hard to get people
it's hard to get guys that are like
stratospheric
jim carrey's come down from the
stratosphere but what i mean is
sometimes those stories
also live at a very at a molecular level
like sometimes they live in
maybe you know what i mean like
something yeah maybe ali who's muhammad
ali's daughter it was a comic
right or like eleanor i mean eleanor
wasn't it but i just mean there are
like those stories are so i don't know
they're just
they're they're in every corner that you
can
i just feel like there's some that fall
through the cracks obviously that's
because eddie is eddie and he's not just
like
and i wouldn't know what unless charlie
told me yeah so let's say charlie was
never on the show
yeah yeah it's like the cascade of look
guys the dominoes of history felt
just right um for us
i'm so happy and i'm a little
embarrassed that eddie didn't say
anything beyond
yeah when he heard my name that was it
was a week yeah
it was not the best i've ever heard i'm
gonna be honest um
he eddie murphy
is he's not undecided on me
i i can't explain it he
i can't explain it but it's he likes me
but he's kind of like i think he's kind
of like what
with me he's like eddie murphy very when
he when i made him tell that story
at the net there was a netflix party
last year
before covet and i made him tell the
story to like a circle of people
uh i've ever talked about it but
when i i'm like a pain in his at i'm
like he's it's the thing that you say
about my brother tommy where we'd say
will you play
a board game with us and he'd go like i
got a poo and do my laundry
eddie has to poo and do his laundry
whenever i
i'm like okay so eddie would you mind
and he's like okay like here
here you go kid but i'm uh
i'm 47 and good at comedy so and even
though
you know i'd seem like a child to him
and he is my
hero of my life
but i got him to say that he at least
knows who i am yes
praises and that is one to grow on um
anyhow bianca so keenan we've checked in
with keenan
he's already invented eddie uh
seth we've checked in with uh now you've
got meghan markle's number
is that what i understand you're friends
with meghan markle oh i forgot to say
uh kaluya i didn't think kaluya was
going to call i just texted him
like you know do the party you didn't i
didn't
i didn't you didn't say yes or no so
when he called i got like a [ __ ]
adrenaline surge
i was like oh i was just so shocked and
surprised
um it was great yes and he uh and it was
great
and we're doing pretty good on our we're
doing a lot of yeah
a lot guys keenan thompson danny kahlua
back
week to week with an eddie murphy club
that we can't show
um what so you watched them megan
did you not watch i watched come on the
first
i watched all of it up till
uh prince harry got in there and then i
watched a little bit of that
um yeah it kind of is it's the
bombshells are
all the thought okay
that because honestly to me this is
i was like this is just a [ __ ] white
family
that's kind of what i thought sorry who
the the royals
okay like the queen and the i'm not
talking to her and then yeah
yeah and the she said this he pulled a
neil he's like
too toxic i gotta cut off like
it's just a white i don't it didn't the
the how dark is the baby's skin was like
bleep
uh also the funny thing is
he's the widest he's whiter than all of
them the baby the baby is so well yeah
i haven't looked at char archie
baby archie baby aren't you um he's like
he's creamier than harry harry's like
red white
well no one's as white as harry yeah all
right
that's like kind of contradiction on
what you just said that he's
anybody because he's he's the only
ginger in the
whole thing but uh
i just love that that that it's like
what
his skin cannot be and i understand
genetics
when you have like it could have been
darker
yeah for sure but also but i mean having
said that if you didn't tell me megan
was
part black i wouldn't know really no
unless you told me
really no there's not there's nothing
about meghan markle that
that i go i don't think black people
would have claimed her unless they knew
do you know what i mean you know how
black people will claim
she looks like a white lady to me it's
not like babe ruth
for white people listening black people
claim babe ruth meaning
before the racial draft they would just
claim people
like you know he's black mm-hmm um and
if and with babe ruth you go yeah i see
what you mean
i see what you mean in terms of features
i see why black people like first of all
no wipe no whiteboard we can can hit
home runs like that
and his features i can see how black
people go
he's he's black meghan markle i don't
she has no features that i think black
people would think
she's black um good thing you're not
black person
why not because i she looks black
really yeah
she doesn't what like i don't know she
looks like
uh she looks as white as my sisters
not the ones you know but like she looks
as white as any white person
to me oh okay i mean who cares i just
she looks big
i would look at her and be like she's
par black
you know you know black people claim
michelle wolf
a lot i don't i think it's she she we
don't we were like is she
part but she has like it's also like you
can be like a dark italian sometimes
well that's michelle
looks blacker than meghan markle i would
say like yeah if we're going to
do the like if we're doing this if we do
it if we're going to no other podcast is
going to do it nobody else
only us um yeah if we're gonna do it i
don't know about
dark but if she if michelle wolf said
she was half like i wouldn't
at all bad night no but there's a lot of
them like rita ora she's
albanian um what's the guy that your
friend snl
big mouth pete davidson yep everyone
thinks he's black he's not
yeah so it's these kind of mixes that
but it's the like slight nuance of oh
is i'm sensing little well yeah it's
michelle looks
red-boned and
i'm just saying he she has as much of
like something going on as
anybody else that gets suspected of it
that's yeah i just wouldn't have
ever thought i never would have thought
it okay
and i still claim you wouldn't have
unless uh no absolutely not you're wrong
i can
what are you talking about i don't care
i don't think they're stupid so you
don't but somehow i have to go down with
your [ __ ]
no no no no i don't think there's
anything race i just think it's like
of all the black people i've seen and
all the white people i've seen
if someone said is she black or white i
go swipe
i don't know i know a lot of very
light-skinned black people yeah
that have a dark smoke you will only
hang out with them if they're
if they're lighter than a than a um
paperback
a lunch bag i think you're confusing me
with your dick oh
so um actually not on this week with all
of the get
don't just be smirch keenan i'm sorry
that you're keenan don't listen to this
vitriol
um so no i don't so i don't know
but yeah no she looks like a black
person today to the untrained eye maybe
not
but i thought i had a trained uh yeah
that's this is this is a
hell of a way to find out all that
ayahuasca guys
are not trained all those beads um
um train did wow
i'm skinned to train today um
so what'd you say okay besides the uh
so white family that's that was my first
takeaway like this sounds like
any not with the skin stuff
um that could not be a white family
meaning no not
in my particular white family like
everything
you're doing a lot of projecting in this
conversation right well my white
family's the only one
i've ever been in uh dysfunctional
family
yeah it sounded this but the thing about
you're not
and the you're not gonna get protection
we need a picture of them was
just sounded like sorry about the buzz
saw in the back nothing we could do
um imagine that it's keenan if you're
it's keenan doing work
over on the near my house um
just to give people a picture imagine
it's a paul money
um
um okay so
that that stuff is where you're like i i
don't know
i believe it a million percent that you
said how
how dark is the baby gonna be she didn't
know who directly said it
she knew she just didn't say well it
wasn't the queen
no no no not the queen is not
a lot of this isn't coming from the
queen the weird thing is they're
it's brand management yeah it is it's
just marketing
yeah and it's you wonder what they're
marketing
their marketing i mean i think they
have to understand that
the problem isn't he even said it he let
it slip and no one's really talking
about he said
she's you get like the the institution
the firm the family whatever the [ __ ]
has a perfect opportunity here
and they don't want to take it and he
pointed to her and i was basically
saying
you guys could make a 2.0 you know
you could make a rebrand voices rebrand
invite her in you know they could do a
creed
what they do rocky but with a black guy
right oh i was thinking creed the band
no
i mean they could obviously take it
higher uh
but i'm saying they could do a creed
where they do a reboot of
the monarchy with black michael b
jordan and uh yeah they could do that
it was weird that they would he's just
like
i brought you a black yeah perfect
that's the perfect opportunity this is
pretty [ __ ] up
this whole thing because i think they
get into the future you know the
monarchy
is served a different purpose in like
let's say even the first half
of the 1900s now it's just
these are our designated celebrities
these are our
countries celebrities you know they
don't really do much i mean
there are mascots there are san diego
chicken yeah
so now it's not about
uh the queen doesn't go and figure out
relations between
countries and all that nonsense so
it's just like how are you going to
change like let your celebrity
what are you you're making well no way
it's that's your exact right like
they're
they're how do you make
like update upgrade your [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
they're
they're like on not dial up but like
whatever was after
it's like you guys they were not ready
to
yeah they were well they were not ready
to make
they're making incremental changes at
their pace which
just didn't is from the 1700s yeah
uh when he was complaining i started
talking like him and i was like because
you know how it feels monarch the
monarchy is silly
there was a game of tag i'm it
and then i'm not it it's like the whole
thing's [ __ ] stupid
that you're a prince the whole thing
that's the thing i wish he said
let's be clear it's all stupid and
random
that my [ __ ] great great great great
great great
grandfather happened to be some [ __ ]
buddy and then they said he was
the church of england said he was from
god and then [ __ ]
right he's not he was a regular guy but
the problem is that he
actually the problem is that there are
people that are
what do they call it like loyalists or
something
in england like it is part of his
culture that whole thing there are
people that that's very important to
like jesus is important here you know
like the queen
and keeping up with the monarchy and
what is allowed and what isn't allowed
so square dance rules like no now we
curtsy and we
switch all that [ __ ] like that is kind
of
loki important to him yeah so
i don't know it seemed like he had to do
a real
like he had to learn a lot more life
lessons than
she did um
meaning he'd never dealt with racism
before
or dealt with it on that level you know
of course not but i mean come on
remember he dressed up like a nazi
because he thought it was cute yeah it
was it was pretty comfy
it was cute in his defense it was pretty
cute i do one no one saw it coming
i do i lost a lot of money because i bet
he would never dress like a nazi
on halloween and i [ __ ] lost him yeah
i do think though that she
i i i'm not gonna say she knew what she
was
like no of course not like that you
can't really totally know that's such a
weird thing right
but um i could have told you there would
be so much racism you thought you were
suffocating
like well that goes to the thing i said
a few weeks ago where it's like
it's usually worse than you think
like it's it's worse you think it's
gonna you'd go
hey he's marrying a uh black girl
even though you know i don't acknowledge
he's black um this married a black girl
i might be a little weird but you don't
think it's going to get to like
what color will the baby's skin be
can we get to can we go and do an
amniocentesynthesis
to see the darkness of the skin can we
get the skin
sample so we know how
how bad this is going to be will it be
human
it is weirdly that
baby is like the jackie robinson
i guess megan's the jackie robinson of
the royal family but
but they i don't think they like anyone
that they marry i don't remember any of
these women
being like getting it easy yeah like
yeah she seems all right
no there's never a mild opinion about
these women well then the
interesting thing was that they're at
least from the interview
it's like the family's take on
everything is just like a toxic family
like
we all went through it yeah it is what
it is that's where it's white family
yeah that's just like
it's abusive it's like well i've had
that
feeling at places i've worked uh where
i'm like
this doesn't need to be abusive just
because you're
a bartender yeah and somehow
somehow you're ordained to
yell at me and call me out of my name
and when i complain about it
i'm making a big deal yeah but you're a
two-bit
like okay whatever i'm getting this is
me projecting now
i'm just saying that there's i'm in this
uncomfortable since you said about
my skin my the women i date
since you uh walked in wearing beads on
your wrist
guys i'm i'm
i'm not i'm beyond a spirit pop-up spear
padre i'm now
i believe a star child i don't know how
else to put it
just i just get called to
wear loose fitting i wanted i wanted to
get a small
wrist uh uh bracelet
from the uh from the tribe and they only
make them
big so i'm we all dealt with it neil
yeah so this is who i am i'm a star trek
you're the megan merkel of i'm the
guy yes um so the funny thing is
no i love my princess and i've always
been a princess man
oh in her in not her defense if you saw
what happened to obama and michelle
how could you ever think it would
be good for you i just when black people
are
pushed to celebrity status
if you just just look at the obama
presidency but i think but weirdly
michelle was hurt by the
fist jab thing huh remember the
terrorist fist jab
her fist jabbing uh like a the cartoons
just gave somebody a pound yeah okay
and and new yorker did a cartoon about
it i don't know i can't remember if she
was hurt by the cartoon
or hurt by yeah in the corner uh
bottom right of the photo bottom right
the black one um
if she was hurt by the cartoon or hurt
by the oh that's so [ __ ] up
um i think maybe it wasn't the new
yorker uh no it wasn't
um why would they do that they were
making
fun of the idea that republicans thought
they were terrorists because she did
that
she they literally called it a terrorist
fist jet i know that's a little too
inside though
that where it's like yeah we're making
fun of it but it's like i mean i get you
i she thought so too and she's she like
likes comedy so
right um she's another one done like me
but does
happen to like well it's things i do
she you have a sign a framed photo of
her
frame photo of her not being that into
it um
eddie thinks higher me than she does but
but that's not saying much okay i like
to think she saw
the mark twain speech and has come
around
i think barack's like no i like that guy
but i don't think michelle's that into
it
so funny anyhow you are so funny
uh no so i'm just saying if you see what
happens to black celebrities in white
countries
how could you it is weird
the good the only upside is
it's more just shitty
than dangerous what what
[ __ ] like that meaning okay
but it is dangerous yeah i guess they
especially for the obamas like the
amount of death threats they got was
well and apparently may you know i've
seen people say like oh
it happens all the time but apparently
megan's the backlash
and the racist and the like the
nastiness she got they've never seen
like it's been like it was like crazy
like yeah like the fbi
the british fbi was like never heard
anything like that
i'm shocked i'm really shocked sorry
sorry for the accents jimmy
jimmy jimmy uh and also i think the
problem is british people have this
thing
where they're almost worse at admitting
they think it's
they don't think they're racist they but
worse than americans
they don't they don't even know how they
could be they're like what
what we go we we've got
jamaica jamaica we have a great
relationships with them
the british virgin islands yeah like i
don't have all that
martinique yeah i just they don't
understand
it yeah i mean obviously we're talking
we're generalizing
but uh like piers morgan what explain
something to me
nihilism tap into your nihilism why does
a person like
it seems like piers morgan everyone
hates
at all angles and even though he'll say
something that maybe
we happen to agree with or we haven't
disagree everyone has had their turn and
totally hating piers morgan but he makes
it in holla or in
he because that's his brand
and he's a good broadcaster like the uh
like um like just i'm the villain yeah
he's just a [ __ ] heel
so he's a heel it's what they call
wrestling a heel
and uh he just is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and people tune in for it because they
know what they're gonna like he's the
host he's like the
matt lauer of what what we used to call
the matt lauer
um he's uh he's the
i don't even know who hosts those shows
anymore in the morning those they're all
they all
yeah they're [ __ ] too hot they [ __ ]
got too hot
in the morning morning their morning
that's why i don't do morning sex
because those guys they went too wild uh
yeah so he's the he's just a
broadcasting brand
and he's always gonna be [ __ ] if he's
not him and the other thing is there's a
lot of white people in england
i i don't know what the percentage is
but i'm betting it's 90
well someone said in criticism of megan
that
so ethnicity
87 damn
why are they so afraid
what um that's a high percentage
how are they so afraid of immigrants
they make it seem like the whole place
is a
[ __ ] chocolate they like invented
white
do you know what i mean that's the
africa of whiteness kind of like they're
the [ __ ]
white supremacy of white supremacy
they're the they're the empire
so they i'm not saying they invented
whiteness but they
kind of like [ __ ] again it's like
in terms of evolution you just go oh
somewhere in europe and then i guess
they swam
to england at some point um
so i mean yeah so that's why a guy like
pierce mark
you can be racist because and everyone's
like
common sense comments it's making a lot
of sense we've done nine different
regions of british accents by the way
you've done a different one every time i
can't do it normally i take
from whatever's close um but someone was
saying that like
okay well colorism is what
allowed megan to marry into the family
but antoine's because she's lights again
because she's like
and anti-blackness is what made them
leave
yeah and so let's say if there were
i don't know it's like at some point
let's just say the issues they have
because they seem like
weird issues like they they could have
not done
these things it's a it's just a weird
[ __ ] branding thing
and in a country that's 87 white
you can i can understand why they
wouldn't understand
no for sure but at the brand but at the
same time and i love
the princess but let's say those things
didn't happen that made them
that forced them to leave let's say
there wasn't so much like unfairness and
like
harsh like retaliatory um
situations they would still be part of
this
super racist thing you know
well if they weren't if they hadn't been
racist
would the monarchy have been racist do
you know what i mean
right or what if they were temporarily
not racist to megan because they knew it
had
branding power yeah but didn't change
anything else
they do that a lot like we're hiring a
black person here
yeah but that doesn't necessarily change
much or it doesn't change the whole
institution it doesn't change the
systemic issues
so i wonder like was it that it's racist
or was it that it was racist to her
well i think in this case both yeah
but i guess if
if it wasn't if they weren't racist to
her would she i wonder
would it would they have came to the
same conclusion eventually
i i hope so there i guess my question
would be how many ways can a monarchy be
racist
other than directly racist to
a fiancee of the guy i think a lot of
ways
i mean charities and stuff i don't
because i know like what i don't know
it's a brand right it's a brand it's the
[ __ ]
colonel sanders or coca-cola coca-cola
yeah it's but it's they're
they're the mo they're the quaker oats
lady
man they're ancient they're whatever any
one of these people okay
of england and the sort of history
like they they've taken swipes at all
these
women with sarah ferguson it was just
you're fat
right you're fat you're like not
classy or sound yeah but so it's does
that mean they're fat phobic or they
just i don't
i i guess i just it's gonna come for you
no matter what they're gonna
that they just show they just that was
their aunt racism was they're in
is the monarchy racist beyond
being racist toward her i have no
[ __ ] idea
well yeah it's like colonialism but what
but they didn't like the history of
england's racist but i'm saying
is the modern brand of
the of royalty inherently
racist today but the problem is most of
them are still
she's the longest reigning monarch
ever and it's one of the longest running
monarchies
ever so if she was i don't know i think
her coronation was in the
teens 19 something i don't know
she had slaves at the corner she still
is the queen yeah so we have a it wasn't
the teens by the way
it wasn't maybe no it was like right
before the world war ii
i don't remember yeah oh that was your
food when did she when did her father
die sorry that's what i was thinking of
1950 coronation no no when did her
father die like when did she know she
was going to be 44. so
what do you do okay so whatever i'm just
saying that she's been alive
she's like 93. so she kind of
has i don't doubt she i guess i'm just i
don't i don't
i don't i can't discern between what's
the people and what's the brand
and what even is the brand if someone
that's been alive for 93 years that is
the head of the monarchy is still there
i mean they bring with them a lot of
old i'm not saying she hasn't changed
and i also when you watch the interview
it seems like
they're not the one bringing up
a lot of the [ __ ] so uh
i i don't know i think the whole it's
just weird that
one i know a lot of the commonwealths
don't like the queen
and don't want to be part of the kingdom
or whatever
so i'm wondering how exactly how popular
really is this i don't but this goes my
i don't even know what this
is do you know what i mean like it's a
thing
that people kind of like feel attached
to though
yeah people do feel weirdly deeply
attached to it so
then you say and that thing they're
attached to is racist
no no no it's it's
didn't you say that the monarchy is
racist
i said it is like inherently because
of you know like how they've colonized
a lot of like african and caribbean
nations they've kind of stopped though i
mean like they stopped
england actually got rid of slavery
before america i understand that but
just because i think it was a mistake
just right but we're not
saying that just because you stopped
doing
like something really [ __ ] racist and
evil doesn't mean that there aren't
institutionalized racism in europe yeah
so i know what you mean
what do you what i guess i don't i don't
even know what it is that's what i don't
it's one of the things where i don't
understand it i don't know
why they have it i don't know what it is
but you're also
not sure if it's racist because i don't
even know what it is okay that's you
not knowing but what i'm but and i'm
trying to get
what that even i believe that they said
all the [ __ ]
but i don't know
what it who's they do you know what i
mean like
it's not the queen and it's just there's
higher ups in the rock
middleton and it's not any of the people
but it's some other person
there's just it's like a it's a company
you know what i mean it is a company and
there's higher ups and there's
and they're all making sure how to
sustain the monarchy in a world where
most monarchies have like been put
through you know what i mean so
i guess that my question is do they get
a cut of these plates i don't know
what do you mean they have a vig on
canada like canada you're going to give
us yeah
they have they get money 3 of the gdp
yeah i'm pretty sure that's how that's
why they're still
in the things we look that up no they
get money
how does work is uh yeah make money work
with their commonwealth
i think where does all the money like
even in
australia royal families paid through a
mix of public and private funds
it comes from a portfolio of land held
in trust that's the thing it's it's not
they don't get a cut of the it's like
this
where they just like they're just
[ __ ] cool with her who
the queen canada doesn't i don't think
canada gives them money
i i but regardless of these like little
details because i'm not a [ __ ]
historian on this
i'm just saying that like what what
we're
talking about is is it racist or not is
the whole institution raises or not
so yeah but i don't know what it is
what's i don't know what the institution
is
because i know they own land so it's
like there's a british
empire thing going on there's a there's
part of
it's called the commonwealth i don't
know there's that's not
i that's like a
like this is my god daughter it's not
anything it's like
but then why is she then why is her face
on all their money don't
understand but you don't know you know
so we can't really have that particular
part you know i i would have answered it
if i know
what i do no no cause you're saying like
you don't i don't know but you're saying
like this wide-eyed thing like
i don't know and i'm saying the only
thing i can speak to
is that it it doesn't surprise me that
it is racist
what she said i nothing surprises me
that it's racist right but you're saying
i don't know with the baby's skin but
when you say
it's racist what is it okay
i'm that okay so what i'm referring to
is racist
is the way the monarchy functions
and their branding like behind the
scenes
i'm assuming it's racist from
certain things how like the queen
i think in like one tour she did uh
she danced with like a uh a head of
state in some
african nation i don't remember and it
made headlines and it was like oh my god
she danced with the black guy
and they were telling her not to do it i
don't know seems a little weird and
racist
yeah of course but i don't yeah i guess
i'm just like i just don't get what
you're
like but what i'm saying canada is
incredibly white
if they're getting money from canada but
we're getting
two down too many pounds we don't know
exactly how much don't know
i everybody everything's racist but when
when
when you say the queen's not racist no i
didn't say i just said she wasn't they
said she wasn't behind
the racist that i'm wondering is who is
the president
of the uh
royal family do you know what i mean
like who's the
head of the brand who's the ceo yeah
okay because i don't think it's the
queen right i yeah it's like
from what i gather and this might be
totally wrong
there's just a lot of aids there are
some that are very high up to the queen
she does have a lot of say in what
happens but she also doesn't have
fully the say in what happens like
they're not allowed to
comment on like certain things and they
are and
but at the same time this is the thing
that confuses me about the whole
thing is that we're making such a big
deal about meghan markle
but prince andrew is like a [ __ ]
child
yeah and has been and is weird
apparently like from the stories i've
read he's molested women
that are now in their 40s
do you know what i mean like he molested
he'd been he's an og
[ __ ] child molester so to me when you
have stories of people who
uh you know they're fighting with him
but they're like
no no just meaning like diana that whole
thing was like
a huge glimpse into like how it's run
because it is really secretive
and it is not like it's not like the
president is comes out and says anything
it was all very secretive
and so these stories that you hear these
stories come out and
it's very like some of them are really
sordid you know so it just feels like
child muscle here this person is
basically like
left like no help no support diana and
like you have all these stories that
come out and you just wonder
like it feels a little toxic so it
is not a far cry to be racist of course
but i'm you seem upset with me because i
don't even know what the monarch
no i seem i'm not upset i'm just
confused how you're saying
i don't know what it is i still don't
know what it is okay but then like and
then it's like okay
i don't know but you're saying this this
byzantine
non-understandable organization is
racist i'm like
what's the organization and people don't
know what the organization
even will with his fine googling skills
hasn't been able to uncover what it is i
don't know what it is it's like
land holdings and but and they don't
know who's in charge
i just think you want information that's
easier to get than we have here that's
all i'm saying so i don't know how to
i'm not saying i don't doubt the races
i just don't understand who it is
and i get why they're racist but i don't
understand what it's like the monarchy's
racist
okay besides her
colonial i don't [ __ ] know like the
colonialism that's
obviously colonialism's racism but i
just don't
i this speaks to how dumb i think the
whole thing is
okay and you're still mad no i'm not i
just don't think i don't know how to
keep having conversations i think we're
on the same page
okay do you know what i mean yeah so
it's like
did you what else came to you in terms
of
did you have was there somebody
i had nothing kind of but sympathy for
her i guess i represent
but i a part of me i didn't even get to
like why to marry him
it seems like just a [ __ ] bad job
yeah i think everyone i don't know maybe
there was just a little bit of i don't
know they liked each other they loved
each other
so you're gonna say no i'm not gonna and
a prince
come on well that's where you get into
like people will marry
right well that's where you get into
like you can't cheat an honest person
huh meaning the a griff doesn't work
unless the person wants to make money
for nothing right so i and i don't think
she's a grifter i'm saying
if there was a
it's the downside of mario prince it's
like i'm a princess now
ah yeah ah and it's like
but you wanted to be a princess they
should have a
some sort of like even when you get
drafted to the nfl they give you some
[ __ ] help
on how it's gonna be like someday blank
we'll talk about it come on vladimir
very funny uh i don't know why they
don't have an orientation it seems
so wild to go from just a whatever
civilian
yeah when she's like i didn't know you
were supposed to curtsy i knew that
how did you not know that right yeah so
to me it's like i don't know you really
want this
thing this brand to survive why
why make it so hard
for people that have no idea so few
people in the world will understand what
it
that's like you know so and when you
want to be a princess
what does that mean what like what do
you think it's going to be
well we also americans have such a funny
love affair but what do you know but
it's like we have a love for her
but yet she seems to know nothing about
it oh no but i think the fantasy of it
so all the good stuff it's never
the princesses you know
you get raped like it's never that's the
first thing i think
is well when did you were you raped
okay i'm sorry what time is the right
example um no but it is there's of
course there's a [ __ ]
it's it there's a i didn't get to you
made your bed now lie in it
but i probably would have if i kept
watching she happens to be very likable
and very seemingly genuine rational i
think they just really like a decent
person
but they dated for years before they
came out
oh got it so i just i don't know it just
seems
like a really strange thing if we think
of it in terms of real life
of course you can be like oh your son's
not getting a name
title no i don't that's the thing i
don't that stuff
i actually truly sympathize with because
that's just [ __ ] up family stuff
100 i don't get when people compare
their lives to them
it's like you have to just go into a
fantasy land
and then you can see how there's
unfairness there's racism you know but
if you take it out of the context
but that's what i mean like it can't all
be a [ __ ] ball
that's where it's like dog it's gonna
well how do you think they got the money
how do you think you can afford that
house how do you think you're sitting in
the cottage and the
that that's where you got to go well
what did you what did you know
why would you wanna why did you have a
fantasy about
a prince and not even in coming to
america
the in the original there's like [ __ ]
static
with like mary that you got to marry a
lady and he's forced to
you know uh we're not going to talk
about the
uh the sequel and the
uh i won't even get into it
there was a whole thing online about how
it was
uh date rape so lord
um no anyways we talked about this for a
second
you're the one who brought rape into
this i know i'm sorry uh
i mean i wanted to earlier so i'm glad
you did um
so the part of me is like i'm 90 like
that it just looks shitty
it looks shitty and it just looks like
[ __ ] it looks shitty and no matter who's
criticizing them
no one wants that life when you it once
you're in it
it sounds awful sounds i have a ques a
black question
do you think tyler perry offered his
house because she's black
yeah okay i cuz i thought maybe he just
was like
i like them or maybe but i don't know if
william maybe he would they're royals i
don't know it's hard to tell
i know because we have a weird love
affair with royals here yeah that tyler
perry's like
i want the princess the exile
i want them to stay at my place
it's not it's like a nice flag no way
wait why does someone online write like
who's going to play the part of toilet
paper
the fact that tyler perry is a part of
this story is
it's very funny then meme's about time
it's like madea with a gun like who's
pretending
that's funny oh my god it's i've got
security i've never seen
and i've never seen a frame of those
movies um uh
but yeah well now they're in santa
barbara and they're they're thriving
so nobody in santa barbara isn't
thriving it's true you go there and you
thrive
uh i don't care about it qualm don't
care about
cuomo wait by the way did you ever watch
kyle dunnigan's cuomo show it's it's me
with cuomo with crabs
i've seen yeah a little bit of it the
intro is
so funny anyways it's uh i don't under
this speaks the thing of like don't
worship these [ __ ] morons
well sorry this is rude to say but
he's an older guy with nipple piercings
i mean
oh right like football the football no
no no i don't i'm not saying all that
i'm just saying he just seems
oh like he's he's a messy little [ __ ]
he's a messy [ __ ] she's the governor
messi a little bit
um and he's single right
yeah or maybe she don't i always feel
like if don't
don't have nipple piercings if you're
married like
having to do one or the other like you
know you're not going to need those
what do you want a commitment or nipple
piercing because you can't have both
oh lord uh i just
the i whenever they're like i'm obsessed
with
you don't know what you're talking about
whenever there's like a new don't
worship anybody
i'm obsessed with the guy from the
cheerleading show on
netflix then it turns out he like
sexually assaulted or or
harassed a bunch of underage boys just
like but you know what
did you ever as a teen cut out i never
did the
cut out magazines and put them on my
wall
i did eddie murphy um and lauren
michaels
close who i had
this is like you're gonna think i'm
kidding oh my god neil
from in do the right thing okay
uh smiley i believe is the character
name who sells pictures of malcolm x and
martin luther yeah yeah yeah
that came out in 89 okay and i
that got spike lee like is the reason i
like saw him doing press or do the right
thing it was like film school
what well what is it i had the picture
of martin luther king and malcolm x
on my wall near the near the
light switch so [ __ ] crazy martin
luther king
and the mountaintop it's just [ __ ]
like i just love that of all the things
you had
just that photo of because because
because
you know what i'm going to do you like
to be inspired it doesn't you know what
guys
it was more of a spike than oh i have a
different story about woody allen
what i it's not it's something that i
remembered watching
part three of woody allen uh the third
nail in the coffin
um uh very quickly
at nick games um there's an elevator
that when you go whatever when you they
give you tickets you take an elevator
okay that's like separate
ridden the elevator spike lee cool but
here's the better one
okay two better ones also where the
elevator
donald trump and woody allen separately
all three
separately yes and uh
donald trump well with donald trump's a
bit of a baby hitler thing
like i don't know why should i have
slapped the [ __ ] it was in like nah
2006 or something okay no that was so
like
melania was there like i don't know any
news no i think melania smelled good i
think i remember
okay um what about with woody
woody allen i uh
asked for a picture with him and he goes
i have to get to my car
and uh but because i'm a dirtbag took
the picture anyway
well let me see if i can find it oh you
want
uh hold on let's keep talking
okay
you know he was trying to do you a favor
yeah yeah photo with me yeah you don't
want
i'm too hot we'll get we'll get into
that later
um i don't even know if i could find it
but it was it was uh
yeah so that's the nick and one time
with spike
spike whatever i'd spike did spell show
so i knew him a little bit right the
funny thing was spike is
one of my idols yeah whenever i see him
he's just bad at small talk so he just
goes
you're shooting he just brings up like
work
straight yeah and it just became like a
joke
uh because he started doing it to dave
too it was funny
that he couldn't think of anything to
say uh
shooting um anyhow
um so don't worship cuomo
and he's got nipple rings what did you
think what did you think was going to
happen
um because you know what somebody made
an observation
to me about somebody that i i've worked
with and do work with
they said that guy has
very available sexual energy who
she was talking about somebody that we
both work with but cuomo
oh yeah i it made me aware it's my
friend kat
said somebody that we work with had a
very available section that's really
funny and it's a thing that i've started
thinking about
it's very good cat is good it's a
description um
and cuomo i believe has available sexual
energy
like you know yeah little flirty you at
variability
you have the most available special
energy
[Music]
uh very available if nothing else
sexual energy well um it's true
you're a lot of my dead for two weeks
before you stop
giving off available sexual energy
that's how
big it is it is and it's weird because i
don't always you don't it's not that's
the thing about it
it's not like you don't it doesn't mean
you want to [ __ ] the person no that's
the thing about available sexual
violence it's like
i wanna some people you do wanna [ __ ]
other people
you want to think you want them to [ __ ]
so then you get
and i'm not saying i have available
security too so like so yeah
it's fun especially for women it's
a honestly it's a good uh
skill set yes unfortunately it's helpful
it's a [ __ ] helpful skill set
and and uh but guys have it too and
somebody tells me
cuomo does it in person like if you've
got nipple
rings and i know and everyone's heard
about there's a way to not
let people know you have them right or
you go i got rid of them
right i don't got them anymore and then
you replace it with
plastic ones so you get their metal
detector you got to think it through
yeah um so he has available sexuality
and men with available sexual energy to
me are way more dangerous
because not mo not every guy has that
whereas a lot of women flirt a lot of
women
can do that yeah a guy that's like a
charmer
can charm men and women gavin newsom has
it too
i would bet he does he has it more
palpably on camera than cuomo does
he's hot
there's the covet stuff i have a lot to
say about dalia
which we want let's kind of get around
to that and like
i it's not i i it's it's
uh it's obvious and then it's not
obvious okay
uh hey do you say stymie or stimmy
stimmy stimulus package oh cause i've
said stymie the whole time
really why what did you think you were
reference what did you think stymie was
short for
stimulus a-e-i-o-u and sometimes
wise stymie no you made a mistake this
is a bad bomb
it's bad bobby all over again um
uh you're being a bad bobby um
uh good for that they got it passed
i actually had an opportunity the first
time
and my accountant who is eddie murphy's
accountant also
said don't just don't take it because if
it comes you know how at a certain point
they were like you know who got stimulus
yeah like he's like you he saw it coming
like don't you don't want to
why would you want 1400 i don't know
it's not
i need money still but i thought only
it's my money no no no it's you have to
make under
like a hundred thousand dollars or
something i do make under a hundred
dollars
for that i do i make under it
to a certain point then i make over it
um
it's like mitch hedberg's old joke uh i
used to do drugs
i still don't do drugs but i also used
to do them
um uh stemi so
congratulations everybody who's getting
this to me
um it's uh you well
the thing that we should talk about is
the town in
uh cameron what time but they gave
people five grand
no they gave people like five hundred
dollars a month
yeah and they all it like helps with
unemployment it helps
it's it's like socialism works a little
bit
a little bit of socialism actually works
it's seth but we can't
is he calling seth's calling call answer
hold on
um hey uh i'm recording a podcast
oh good for you so you're gonna be on it
saying good for you um
all right well i just want to support um
uh
squarespace wait a minute anchor
and um manskey no what do we do
anchor and uh spotify spotify pandora
let spotify be the anchor to your
listening
pleasures fantastic uh that was so great
the video and the funny thing was that
eddie didn't really acknowledge me with
that much warmth
but it's very funny
i will thank you for joining us i love
you too bye
you guys love each other he said he
loves me first years ago and i was like
[ __ ] it
we're saying we love each other i that
that's a heart melter yeah
it's really cute when you've been in
chivas long enough guys
everybody loves you um
so stemi
and uh and the what's out stockton yeah
like it's
it like [ __ ] giving people money
works yeah
give them give give them money it seems
like oh you're trying to buy your way
out of problems
money [ __ ] solves a lot of problems
buy your weight on problems is
the right way to solve problems yes it's
like first of all
if you don't like buying your way out of
problems then you don't like america
it's true because that's what we do
that's what we do
um so uh good for you car
stockton and good for you stimmy um
covid even you know last week when i
said cove it's flat and it's
people were like [ __ ] bad science
it's like
no dog it's about 60
000 people a day are still getting
infected you don't get
no there's not it's [ __ ] look at the
chart you know what's funny about
covid is after kaluya wouldn't say
lebron yesterday wouldn't say either
interesting
do you think lebron watches i don't
think he does
okay um although in terms of what do
they think of me let's play a game
called hey what do they think of you
neil okay i think lebron
likes me more than michelle obama and
eddie murphy
okay so neil has like a rolodex of
no you're moving down well you just it's
a human interaction it's a human warmth
level he was
very warm he he knows who i he knew who
i was before i met him and knows do you
know what i mean like he's [ __ ] in
high school and spell shows on so
oh yeah yeah yeah you always forget
lebron is actually not as odd
yeah he just looks 70 and has since he
was 13. now he's not gonna like you
um uh okay
so but yeah so black sorry for black
people you can't say
what you're doing with the with the
vaccine
if you're a famous black person you just
gotta just do it that's between me and
my family it's a woman's
right to choose me and will were talking
for the podcast and
he was like so it's probably over
and i was like no it's not over but i
feel like yeah
no he meant like okay are things winding
down but i just think a
par a portion of it is winding down
you hope that the worst part's over
right like i hope
le the high anxiety confusion
of last year won't
repeat itself um
i don't think that if you look at jan it
actually was this year
january ninth was the peak and then
of infections oh and like you're talking
about last year
no this year january 2021 was like the
peak
if you look at the channel that was when
they were like it's going to surge from
the holidays
yeah that was the surge it was like a
hundred and forty
thousand people a day or something or
maybe more it might have been two
thirty it was bad it was just atrocious
so
that's i think definitely over
whether it's a thing there's a new thing
there was a thing on
on 60 minutes last night where like
antidepressants work
so i'm good i'm kidding what do you mean
um there's a certain antidepressant that
for some reason
knocks it out interesting
um what didn't you say there's people
with some sort of
uh lymphoma
non-hodgkin's lymphoma that uh
kovid actually cleared no uh
i don't think it was me but no no you
showed me a photo of uh
lungs like yeah of a some type of cancer
that was cured from having cobit
yeah you don't remember nah vaguely okay
look i
show a lot of people a lot of things you
really do um
okay so yeah i hope i think it i
it's never going to be that [ __ ] bad
i mean i don't know how bad these
variants are but if
there's a hundred million vaccines that
have they've been
administered 90. so 90 million vaccines
have been administered by
this point and in a country of 320
million people
we're getting like it's just gonna it's
a numbers game it's just another like
this many people have been vaccinated
and
this many people have been already
infected still have antibodies
it needs the the buyers needs
houses and we have a housing shortage
in our country we have a viral housing
shortage
um are you gonna
travel in the summer safely i'm hoping
to start a show in new york
in august that's the gang
coming soon
uh so i'm hoping to start a show i
think i i like to i mean if you look at
just the amount of infections in
california we only had
the whole state for the week had like 5
000.
yeah and in the country we're under 40
000
um people in the hospital now which is
so low which is yeah at one point it was
130
or something yeah so we're doing
everything's trending in the right
direction it's just trending slowly
um it's like uh
my career
that's the truest thing i think i've
ever said in the podcast it's growing
all right let's hurry up a little bit um
so texas rest in power king
is opening 100 open
for business they love saying open for
business it's just like
you just barely made it they have more
infection than california they have more
infections there's
they have so many issues in texas yeah
where like don't
don't just turn the lights on huh
before you open for business you're
gonna need boiling water
boiling snow to yeah flush your poopies
poof so i'm now mad i'm the tough talks
coming out
uh yeah so what's a kobe pass is that
the is that the thing with the
what you wrote coveted pass on your list
oh that's
one of them those are that have been a
bad bobby
being bad sometimes i write neil and it
doesn't make sense that's fine but
they're funny i know you wanted to talk
about coveted sweetie
they're full they're full words uh there
was an
article in cbs sacramento
it was not all right it was it's a tv
station uh about how there really was no
actual exodus from california this year
or in 2020 like you know everyone's
moving it
it's not true no people there a lot of
people moved out of san francisco but
they just moved to other parts of the
bay
right or the exodus that i
saw was that when you looked at the
numbers it just um
less people came into california yeah
than
than normal normally and
the amount that moved out was it no it
was like a little bit of an update
but it was it's a perceived it's also
like
two hundred thousand people it's not
exactly that's a good thing what
yeah that's exactly it's like the
streets are empty
um i parking's free now and then people
like oh well the the rentals
a lot of people want to lose their
parents yeah didn't mean they left the
yeah doesn't mean they're doing good um
it doesn't mean they're mad at
california it means
they don't got the money uh
dr seuss your thoughts okay
my thoughts on dr seuss are everyone's
making a big deal out of it
uh the truth of it is of course the
truth is so much
milder than the headlines so it's just
the the
the um the estate yes is saying we're
just gonna take
these six books off the shelf and
they're
like way less known dr seuss books yeah
there are ones where i'm like oh that's
a long title
one has the n word in it which is pretty
rare
neil um so
they they six books and
the funny thing is i read an article
that
and i didn't remember this i vaguely
remember it but how
um when the lorax came out um the
conservatives were
so against dr seuss because it was
preaching for like environmentalism and
so
fox news i mean everybody there were
i think in mendocino there was like the
lumber
union wanted to ban the lorax because it
attacked their uh it attacked
their industry and so there were calls
to ban the book
ban everything when the movie came out
they wanted to ban it
and now when it's an environmental issue
it's a threat and we have to ban it but
one it's a racist issue
it's uh cancel culture we have to
protect it well everybody's got their
it's the it's it's a common sense when
they want to do it and
it's cancelled culture when they when
they don't like it so it's just
very funny how they wanted to cancel the
same dr
seuss there's no yeah there's no but
that implies that there's any logic to
the
republican like i mean it's whatever i
and by the way it's came from the estate
there was no demand like
they were like look this is [ __ ] up
i'm sure that they'll i don't know
what a lot of it's the drawings so
they'll probably replace the drawings
and re-release them
and then make money that way but they
didn't they're like it's not good for
our brand to have this out there
yeah um that's the opposite of the
royal family yeah they really don't race
isn't bad for the brand
whereas uh in whereas the royal family
was like inclusion's bad for the brand
we are the uh
[ __ ] i don't yankees um the yankees
the new york yankees you can't have like
facial hair
it's just some weird [ __ ] like if you're
a yankee it's some other
sure it's gotten better but it used to
be like you shave
and you comb your hair yeah i used to
work for whole foods and they
you had to wear black socks if you
didn't have black socks
it was an issue um
wow so you'll be hearing from me
um nike kid had a
um a woman who worked for nike her son
was a shoe broker
whoops uh
whoops i look if you're asking me
neil have you ever been sent nikes and
then took them to
undefeated flight club
nah not me yeah
if i can yeah take him down defeated
taking flight or taking a flight club
make it quick what happened was the
truth is
i was given an incredible pair of
uh jordan 11s in red
we'll go ahead and pop that up the
burgundy
yeah the red one the velvety no actually
it was the sevens
sorry yes
all red and i
gave them to jamar neighbors and he took
them
no and then i went to flight club the
next day and saw that they were worth
750
and i was like i got a call
i gotta get i gave the kids package and
uh meanwhile i was sitting on 7 50. i
didn't even know it
um so i think after that i brought in a
pair
and i don't remember but you took them
back i didn't take them from jamar
sometimes jordan would send me shoes
just
off the muscle uh just because i worked
i did [ __ ] with them
yeah um and so they would send me like
you know nice you know i know but some
of the here's the thing about jordan
some of them are like [ __ ]
four pounds each they're not they're not
all comfortable they're not
comfortable they're really like boots
one of the ones that you
you we use for like blake's credit yeah
they're so cool looking but
i can't i can only wear them if i'm not
going to be moving a lot
yeah i have to walk briskly they're like
uh
gravity boots basically yeah like you
choose yeah you're like
if you need to lose weight quickly
you'll be like
um you'll put on your um your martin
lawrence
coma suit and your jordans and [ __ ]
i'd like to used to do the joke on the
champion martin lawrence the only guy in
the world who ever caught a coma
caught a coma he put on one of those
workout suits and caught a coma wait is
this a real story
yeah martin was in a coma no i know that
but what happened was running
and he was you know when like fighters
will wear like yeah i don't know what
the [ __ ] they're like plastic and they
keep you they make you they make you
sweat like crazy martin was trying to
lose weight
and uh wore one of those and uh
caught a coma that's a rude photo
um emerges from coma yeah in 99.
this is 22 years ago that's how old i
am i remember when mart in fact how old
am i
martin caught a coma and you know who
had to do all the press for him
dave chappelle for blue for the movie
blue streak
dave had to do like had to just fill in
for him
[ __ ] happens living
um papa john
uh this hit close down because papa
john's trying to stop saying
inward that was so how could they come
up with this
it was so it's so weird like i'm just
trying to get rid of what are you
[ __ ]
talking about you gotta think about it
you
dog 18 months how often were you are you
is he is he does he is he a rapper
is he he got he probably is he making a
mixtape what the [ __ ] is he doing yes he
how i thought you're i don't know you
were lord pop
this is why i don't [ __ ] with papa
john's but by the way i think shaq
owns it now i thought that was papa
murphy
what are you talking about jack owns
papa john's yeah and if you think he's
ever called jack the n word
there's no i bet shaq's like who are you
in what context could you possibly be
using the n-word
seeing that the guy who just took over
your company
is technically to some
well uh all right and now we'll talk
about dalia
quickly we have a song jesus
we need a segment we need a song called
we're going to talk i mean you want to
talk it's really the
trouble in the winter
[Music]
i'm dreading talking about it uh yeah
because i
gave him first of all you read the
charges
it feels like a long time ago
uh just because i had a big weekend but
maybe i'd like no
i just had a long meaning the charges
came out against them last
week right i just the lawsuit
yeah everything feels like so long yeah
um but
uh i i
wanted to believe
that uh
someone i knew wouldn't do [ __ ] like
that
and it i again it's all allegedly
um but i just didn't
it it's you know i didn't i wasn't
reading the suit like rolling my eyes
i was reading and going like yeah that
that's
very possible uh and i'm assuming
there's some kind of proof
um the
it's i feel bad for the
woman and i feel
i feel uh
i got to a place with
with chris because i i don't want to say
that i did ayahuasca this weekend but
let's be honest look at this
look at this wristband and tell me i
didn't do ayahuasca i got a crazy
wristband
yeah um but i got to a place
of empathy meaning
he must be incredibly scared
just straight up like he must be
incredibly scared
and uh and i'm not saying like
i i i'm that's in no way to belittle i
like feel
bad for the woman and i feel uh
empathy for chris for being
most likely terrified just as like a
person
it's a bad feeling uh whatever you did
like i happen to be like i i'm gonna be
a bad podcast for the next 10 minutes
because i am when it comes to that
i'm like very i'm in a uh
ayahuasca it's like an empathy [ __ ]
charge so i just
i just got like i just ate the empathy
coins um and i just have empathy for
the situation he finds himself in and i
then you get into if he did it is that
the kind of person he is
or is it a thing that uh
he got caught up in which is another
kind of
ayahuasca thought of like what not what
are we responsible for but i just feel
bad that
he if he did the stuff in the case
it's a bad way to be
um it is you have the power and you have
but it's a negative [ __ ] impulse
um and so i have empathy in that regard
and uh
the difficult thing when somebody you
know is accused of something it's
you can either be
loyal and
potentially look stupid which you could
say i look stupid
um or
you can be
kind of
spineless and just assume it's true and
like
i know nothing and i'm assuming it's
true and i'm and
it's a it's we're all in a bad position
anyone who knows him is in a bad
position because then i have to decide
and i don't want to be either i don't
want to be a [ __ ] loyal [ __ ]
or a spineless uh
um i don't know what you call it like
believing accusation against any
friend right it's a shitty position
uh the other thought i had was
i would like to it since cove what i've
realized i need to be
i obviously like love comedy right been
pretty clear about that
uh love comedy love
comedians and i need to be more
discerning about
giving human beings
funny human beings comedy
credit for
giving them human credit for being funny
when some people like seth's a [ __ ]
prince of a person he lo he said he's
the one who said
i love you first so
wait that's he's not whatever so i guess
i just it's like one of those things
like as an adult man i have to be like
huh i gotta be
um
intelligent about who i give
credit to or you know what i mean like i
i
but i don't know to do over i guess i
would just say nothing
with chris with dalia maybe the like
tweets
i think the tweets were just like
maybe for every side better to not
throw your hat in well if only you told
me
if only someone named binky told you
not to do that um yeah but yeah you know
just because sometimes
no matter who it is no matter what the
situation is
some things just need to it's something
that you're not directly connected to
yeah need to just breathe yeah
so and especially when it was so
charged and was happening on twitter and
there was so much like updates and
i will say i'm like allergic to lynch
mops
like i just [ __ ] i it's like
that was why you have to but yeah you
have to
[ __ ] know that this is true right
and that's what triggered you you were
trying listen and you're
neil's the best he was trying to be a
good
he was trying to do what he would want
someone to do for him yeah
but the problem is there's so many that
is like the type of argument that they
say you know well they're it's their
worst [ __ ] it's the it's
it's bringing a knife to a gunfight it's
like bringing up bringing a like
wait a second to a let's go yeah there's
no way
you did a all things considered and
there's no way to do in all things
considering
it's no it's the the lowest hanging
fruit and i'm like
guys you know there's higher right and
there's just it you can't
you just have to let it yeah it has a
it's a bell curve
it will get worse and then at some point
it just
won't be as intense and then you can
do something if you want but yeah but
yeah but i
uh the problem is you don't want someone
to come to you yeah it's like i don't
want my friends
to do that if somebody was like i would
well first of all if somebody if seth if
i got into a
um scandal
seth would actually uh
he would not he would call me but he
wouldn't
to pay for it but he'd tell you i love
you yeah of course
uh but he wouldn't he wouldn't but you
can't ask people
that's what i'm saying is i'm like i
hope people do it it's like but at the
same time i also know
that i would i would like to think
if i was in one of those problems that i
would say to people
like take this gun you gotta go
like i'm i'm i've got a bunch of [ __ ]
i'm about to eat
and i don't want to get this on you like
like i the
the some [ __ ] zombie bit me yeah like
i'm gonna you gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here so you would
but again i'd like to think i would i
don't know
if you would uh tell people to get the
[ __ ] out
no because you do love a loyal [ __ ]
well how would you
um you don't you wouldn't want to ride
no of course not but i but i get that
people have
bigger [ __ ] i wouldn't be mad at so
i'd be like you have a [ __ ] franchise
you're
in charge of like i'm not going to be
like okay is it
is it more important to have leverage
that for me
what's more important okay a job that
pays you millions of dollars a year or
me would it be more important to have
people
behind the scene support and say nothing
in the public
or even though let's say they had
evidence and they knew it was totally
false you are
that your past life's coming to fruition
falsely accused of murder
but would you care if just because at
some point it would be
a friend watching you go down it's like
yeah but what choice do they have but
would you
be okay within that i would like to
think i would be
i would like to think i would be okay
but i'll also tell you this
i i met i sent dalia
of voice memo just saying i wish you
strength
on saturday so like while you were on
ayahuasca
no i wasn't on it
but the message occurred to me i'm here
from celestial court
chris they i stole my phone back no but
i i
i'll tell you as a human being that's a
very scary situation he's in
and uh just as it was
what louis was in was scary and what the
people i know that were more scary
and and uh and also
the situation that they put the
potentially
allegedly put the people the women in
also scary
and if i knew them
i i would like to think i would have
sent them a voice memo saturday as well
i think you would have you look at me
you know i will i know um
um so
yeah i mean i don't i it's it's a real
it's a uh we're gonna go it's quadruple
bummer
it's a super duper duper bummer super
factor bummer
does that sound better quadrifecta maybe
quadruple quadrophenia
um uh it's just a really bad
quantity you know yeah sarah talked
about this a lot
when louie got his stuff is she's like
what do you do i've known the guy for 25
years he's one of my closest friends
i don't want to not be friends with him
he i still have
all those you know
uh
memory it's you know it's the it's like
eric if i do talk about bill cosby
she's like that guy's a an amazing
contributor
to uh
black life human life american life yeah
it's atrocious what he did but but i'm
trying to have empathy
so i'm it's pardon me you guys if i'm
white what white badou no
i do um no but that's the that's the
that's what
you know you want to get to it yeah i
think it's ironic that my ayahuasca
bracelet is now this whole conversation
my ayahuasca bracelet's trying to get
away from this conversation
it's like he doesn't deserve us
he's been trying to tighten his bracelet
yes the entire sentence
not a nervous affect at all make no
mistake
um so uh
so yeah so those are my those are my
feelings about about
um chris is that i i wish
him strength and uh it's a scary
situation and i wish the
uh young woman
uh strength also
so i guess cancel me
anything anything to add no just
listening taking it all in
no i know but what do you why do you
feel like i feel like you're like i'm
digging myself a hole or something
no i think you're part of it no i no i
think that's
you thinking that okay i'm just like
you're his friend and we've talked about
him on the podcast and you did have some
sort of
involvement so i'm just i
honestly i'm active listening to what
would
what it's like to be in your particular
position you know like
i will say i don't feel uh
i don't feel um
[Music]
like i betrayed women and i think that
was the accusation
like when i wrote those tweets i don't
believe it
oh i didn't think that at all well
you're not gonna believe this
people on twitter the great people of
twitter
uh i just think that
[Music]
i don't know there's some people who
don't talk about it at all that are
friends there's some people that
do a little bit and i just it's just
interesting
like i said before it's like
uh-huh it's hard to have interesting
failure
now he's using it now he's using the
ladies know what i'm talking about
um i think now is the perfect time to
talk about oral sex
so yeah no it just it's like there's
like we said before there's no
real blueprint for anybody whether
you there's an accusation if something's
happened to you
if you're getting accused of something
friends of all these people
yeah so i don't know i just think the
social media aspect of how to navigate
through these
things you know before we have
let's put in laws so people can get due
process
but there's no rules or
even uh guidelines or even just
uh like a
culture of giving people due process and
yeah the
day of social media even what whatever
side you're on or whatever
position you play so hearing you as like
a friend of
or an associate of that someone has made
a statement
in the past you know when
just your reaction to it is interesting
so well i'm trying to be
uh consistent in some way and the good
thing about being old
is that i don't i'm like what are you
gonna like
there's nothing this is between me and
me it just is a whole it
unfortunately there are real lives and
you know trauma at risk but
on some weird level it feels it just
sometimes just kind of feels
like a weird experiment like okay now
this now
add this element and how does how does
she
react how does she does it make her less
she's more accessible what if someone
finds
you know i don't know it just him the
whole thing is very
i just it's weird honestly uh it's
new it's new so it feels weird it's new
it's a new
thing in human history it's a new like
there's just
social media it's another checking
balance so it's a new media
new form of communication and a new
set of laws it's a new set of laws that
we're not all familiar with and
everyone is like we're all kind of
running through a minefield
yeah not really but so when someone
steps in one place it's like whoa that
is
can't do that and we get it okay yeah we
saw how it plays out from this side of
things you know
it's so i don't know it just it's it's
funny you see people like
this has nothing to do with the delia
thing but you see people calling out you
know we all get together and we'll call
out a person for racist behavior
and then the person who called out the
races also has raised behavior so it's
just we get to see
like i think if there wasn't social
media
karen's in social media go hand in hand
i don't think karen
quote unquote would have come about
without social media
and uh mona like the ability to respond
if something against something
it's karen's or like an eye the beholder
basically well no i just mean that
we have a new part of our culture with
um social media so we have karen's came
from
social media if social media exists
let's say it just we developed a
different way with technology
that wouldn't have been a thing we all
were like there's an actual it's a
funniest time video it's america's
finest it's a blooper right so
it's a blooper and a practical i used to
love bloopers shows
i thought about that all of them were
alfonzo robero everyone was like wait we
told the warm-up guy at fresh prince to
do something crazy
it's all about watch alfonso react uh no
so it's just
a new thing it's just a new it's a new
technology
and also the it's a new
uh expectation of men when it comes to
women
that yeah yeah this specific thing but i
also thought
when it was really
booming like 10 years ago i feel like
we're gonna have
like psychological conditions that are
gonna be like let's say in 20 30 years
we're gonna have labels for a lot of
things that we're just now
experiencing you know what i mean yeah
so that
that uh yeah it'll be
it will they'll realize a certain point
like this is [ __ ]
bad yeah like dog this shit's bad
this social media [ __ ] is bad don't have
rules you can't have likes or we can't
do this because
it like you know it just takes a while
and we're in the
it's like when people were playing
around with x-rays
put your face in it neil was alive
you know madame carey was a friend i
went to the premiere of x-rays
um anyhow i feel like you did it all
so that yeah we did all of our lists
let's go to some emails will
it's time
[Music]
hey neil and bianca it's mitch from
mississippi
so it means nothing to me no problem
with the mask man like
i've been wearing a mask since march
17th
last year all these [ __ ] down
here in mississippi were like you're
crazy ain't [ __ ] gonna happen
and i've been on point day one
and i'm really starting to have some
serious fatigue with it
i'm like turning it's almost like i've
been brainwashed by these [ __ ] down
here
like they're starting to win me over
it's it's tough man
i'm having a tough time like it's
[ __ ] having a blast sounds like
you're having a ball just want to get
your guys thoughts opinions anybody else
going through this kind of thing
like where you just like come on man
i've been doing right this whole time
and you [ __ ] [ __ ] it all up now the
vaccine's out
give me a break so what nil
phil and yeah thank you thank you thank
you guys love you
i wish i think the only thing i would
have added to that
that uh email was uh him saying i'll
tell you what
i'll tell you i'll tell you what i'm
having a heck of a time with this mask
[Music]
wear a [ __ ] mask it's not that hard i
i can't
believe the amount of
we've been talking about for a year how
what [ __ ] babies people are
about all everything like no
i think so i wanted to do a joke but
i think somebody did a version of but
like
people if there was a world war now the
amount of
complaining people would do like i'm
stationed in
i know [ __ ] germany man my buddies in
hawaii
i got transferred trench foot no you
don't that's the athlete's foot oh it
feels
i got it in the trench though it feels
trenchy
um so i don't wear it man it's
yeah it's it's tiring it's a you know
what you
also well might happen uh if you wear it
long enough you forget you're wearing it
that's what i found yeah where i forgot
if kaluya forgot who's wearing it
yeah it was weird he was he i realized
he came
home oh and uh
um he's from mississippi so he might
be wearing it yeah that's a weird uh
accent no no no
our caller yes uh so he might be wearing
it
24 7. i mean we don't know what he's
talking about he sounded like he was
wearing it more than
most people i didn't get that
really i just he's like sick of it oh
yeah i'm sick of it too
technically but i'd be i don't mind
but it's not uh you know like a viral
infection kind of sick it's just it's
sort of annoyed kind of sick and like
tired of it
i don't get the like mask i like the
mask
i gotta say i like the masculine you
know what the mask has done
it's it's it's made uh
it's made with women it's made it's a
couple fives into
sevens and eights and we
almost grew up on america's next up
model and it's called smizing
yeah which is called smiling with your
eyes oh
please okay by the way little uh
do you have something uh no co-created
by kenny bears
oh yeah i know that yeah i didn't know
that you didn't i didn't until like
recently and then i'm always like ken
mock can you bear us
nice um uh yeah
it's funny all the uh with the masks and
the fake eyelashes out here
it works yeah it's i'm surprised when i
get hit on with my mask
uh it's like as a guy can you tell if a
girl is attractive
you can yeah i mean if you do this you
have nice eyes like
thank you i i it pains me to say it's
oh um it pains me to say it but
no but like if you a girl has nice
symmetrical eyes and like
a nice mask like a nice nancy pelosi
style mask
forget it i it's boner city
do you still get do you notice you can't
see your
whole face or do you still get that girl
where i'm
with the guy girl thing just like the
when she's hot
yeah like a mask
i'll open that up open up a chest to
sexual energy
you re you you take off the mask can a
sexual energy will pass
um you take off the mask she hasn't
it's all happened look i've been through
it all wow over there
you just say uh you get a fake phone
call
and you get out of there you say set's
calling and they get upset
seth my mama myers he loves me damn it
um so just uh bear with us
stay strong mississippi bear with it but
i
like i've been doing a lot this week i
send you strength and i send you empathy
well you know what neil has ones which
now you gave me and wilson neil they
make you look like a duck
so i don't love them i feel like mother
goose a little
but very comfortable yeah
uh i bought a box and they scratched my
nose up so i might have some of those if
you guys need them
they're better looking they're they're
better looking
i'll explain what i was about to say
well goodbye
you've got mail hey guys came to the
show for neil
stayed for bianca's charm and the lovely
dynamic the two of you share
i'm 24 and has been four hours
persistent depressive disorder sure um
and i wanted to hear your thoughts on
the guilt that comes with depression
um i have memories of you know
experiencing depression all my life
but i have i uncontrollably compare my
life to those who i believe have had it
much worse
um i've i feel like i have a similar
relationship with depression as neil
but you know without the abuse that
stems from it
um i've recently been taking zoloft
um and worried once the honeymoon phase
of soul oft and
what am i to do with all this guilt i
have for taking in the first place
and what to do with secretly taking a
pill every night just
isn't cutting it i love you guys love
the show god bless
well um since millions of people listen
to podcasts it's not a secret anymore
um the i mean i
you know i the guilt i i don't know if
i never felt i never felt that much
guilt about it
a lot of people i know friends that were
so
um uh offended when it was suggested to
them by their therapist
and just was like no well that's the
that's
were they white yeah because i think
there's more
obviously more of a stigma in the black
community like white people
thankfully have woody allen to look up
to
i think it's more many in many ways
that he is an icon in so many
departments i think it was more
uh i can handle like i don't need
yeah it's i ain't no [ __ ] yeah that's
how you know [ __ ] uh
i you guys know that i have no problem
saying that i'm a [ __ ]
um and
so i don't i that you do feel like
a failure for having depression you do
feel like what's wrong with me
so but that's not guilt guilt to me
would be
uh why do i have this and other people
don't meaning
i have an advantage here um
and that that yeah um yeah guilt is
weird i don't think that's the right
word or he's saying he compares himself
to
uh people people worse than him yeah but
that's you know
lighting up on yourself that's uh that's
also like
immutable and not
helpful because somebody's always got it
worse yeah so
and you know just lighten up
on you like don't go so hard on yourself
like you're
taking a pill that helps you yeah so
and you it's not like you're taking it
recreationally
you're lucky that you have access to it
yeah you live
you're lucky to live in a western
country but i don't think you're popping
nine ten of them a day
and it's not like xanax where it's
making you like i'm
[ __ ] zonked on zoloft and also
i don't think anybody who's taking an
antidepressant is
feels like they have their kill in it
you know what i mean
yeah that's i will say that there's
always a thing where people want you to
get off them
like i've gotten off and i've got
knobsol off since i started taking
ayahuasca and
and felt the need to go back on no
cool it's right but
i don't think there's i don't i guess
it's better
but like i said i always saw it as as um
[Music]
like having high cholesterol or
something that you just can't control
but
some times people have bad side effects
i mean
pills have side effects so i think
that's the i feel like you didn't have
that fat
i would yeah i would just my only sound
effect is i [ __ ] too good
wow give him that dude look at my d
i'll tell you what i'm talking about oh
my god so i got i'm
out here [ __ ] no i that i didn't
really have many side effects
so uh don't feel guilty feel
better hi i'm neil brennan and you know
when you've got
hooks the way i've got hooks uh we'll go
to the next one please goodbye
you've got mail oh now it's up to us to
read them
okay hey bingles and crinkles i love it
i don't know what that means but i'm
offended the holidays have come and gone
and i meant to write this email
in a more time appropriate manner but
i've been busy doing other stuff fair
enough
i'm an american male and live in the in
a first world east asian country
pretty cool job which is rant which has
a random work schedule and i sometimes
have stretches of free time which is
you may have guessed it very conducive
to dating multiple women at the same
time
i hadn't guessed that um some
relationships have
have a bit of closeness others are more
physical in nature
i'm sure you know the deal i'm being as
vague as possible so as not to get
myself
an invite to the dry snitch olympics yes
the 2020 olympics may be in question
but the dry snitch olympics committee
does not sleep
this kid's got a real wit to him we like
it
um with some fortuitous breaks last
holiday season i was able to navigate
the holidays fairly smoothly
i don't personally like societal
mandated uh gift-giving like valentine's
day but christmas is special to me
at least back home in the states however
in a country that recently adopted a
fact similarly of christmas
from the west being expected to do
traditionally christmas things here
feels a bit disingenuous
and irks me on some level so i didn't
spend a lot of money on anything like
that
uh and just did uh small but thoughtful
gifts for the girls who i actually
want the girls i actually have a good
connection with the girls who i have a
mostly physical relationship with
didn't get me anything and i didn't get
them anything which seems very
reasonable to me
with all that being said i'm wondering
if neil and bianca has ever gone through
a holiday season while seeing multiple
partners
and if so how did you go about it what
pinkles thinkles and how crankle's
finger
[ __ ] kid uh
bianca you're gonna go ahead um
i don't see i've dated multiple guys at
the same time but i don't
i'm not [ __ ] multiple guys at the
same time so i don't know if that's the
same definition i'm the opposite i've
[ __ ] multiple people at the same time
but haven't dated multiples
that's a shout out to patrice o'neill
for that joke construct
um so when he said
hey i have a very funny uh text update
from something we talked about on the
show someone i dated texted me about uh
give me a keyword uh
avoidant okay so so
when he says here i
this thoughtful gifts for the girls i
actually have a good connection with
and then the girls that it's mostly
physical so he's out here
relationship in and [ __ ] a little bit
that's a little weird i feel like you
have a connection with
one and you're [ __ ] a few or
you know for a guy at least i
like what a relation like i i don't
you're getting like like into it you
ever feel like
you never physically
like it's good sexual chemistry to the
point where it feels
like uh
very connected yeah
okay so should you get that person a
present
but it's even if you're not social yeah
it's only physical but it's
it's anointed that's stupid
um yeah
i mean i don't i'm not uh i'm i'm not a
gift giver
i'm like uh i'm a random gift giver i
love a random
uncertainty i'm like i'll get if i have
you're a gift giver of your ever away
[ __ ] give
whatsoever there's no emotion behind it
at all
um yeah i just i i'm hung up on
multiple girls out that he has a good
connection with giving
them all gifts and then there's the
second tier that he's just kind of yeah
i don't think you need to tear them
and i also think uh little thoughtful
things are as
helpful or as positive as a big
as a lexus
but i do not do holiday stuff with
someone i'm not
uh more serious about i was talking to
somebody recently
who was celebrating a birthday and a
valentine's day
they were near each other and he he was
like uh he's like i gotta not
talk to any of the women i'm talking to
for like a week
oh it was his it was his birthday and it
was her valentine's day of course
because it's for the ladies
yeah of course and he had to like
withdraw completely
just because he's like i can't it wasn't
he wasn't serious enough with any of the
women
to be like he didn't want them to know
was his birthday
and then like what do we do and then you
have to be like ah
yeah yeah you know it's funny that just
made me think of
if you're dating like
valentine's day is hell if you're
casually dating
valentine's day's oh my god
it's like a heavy it's a heavy it's just
not worth it
it's the for some reason as a culture
we've decided to have a
what are we conversation as a holiday
mm-hmm so
it's terrible what are we doing
um yeah that's uh it's
it's not good now the text i got okay
was from a woman i dated who listened to
the podcast
and we were talking about the
the thing of dating someone and it's
like dating someone with avoidant
personality uh or connection uh
attachment styles like
go into cheesecake factory and they
don't give you
right the buzz is a nub they don't give
you a butt a
buzzer nub and she texted me and she's
like was that were you talking about me
and i was like
no and then she wrote by the way
that's exactly what it's like to date
you yeah
that's so funny i was like huh
okay that's weird though on her she's
like were you talking about me yeah
okay because i'm talking about you yeah
i think she was like are you projecting
and i was like no
oh and she's like okay because it's
you're talking about yourself
yeah well you admitted your avoidance
right yeah yeah and i'm gonna avoid it
i love that description yeah great it's
like
the restaurant's still open your table's
been ready just you know
it was ready you just you're busy with
uh putting ketchups in other ketchups i
had to do roll-ups and do roll-ups
gang game
i moved to california from the philly
area 10 years ago and got involved in
the nonprofit world i currently live and
work in san francisco mostly supporting
isolated seniors
cool um well that's nice but my work
also
extends into working with ever-growing
uh
with our ever-growing homeless community
as the level of wokeness continues to
move further and further left i find
myself censoring myself more and more
my joke about uh my pronoun being a
b-flat played on a baritone saxophone
no longer gets used it's really funny um
that's a good joke that i don't quite
get but i
it is a good job i was at a conference
on harm reduction there was an
organization
sharing information about harm reduction
and pregnant women basically they were
applying harm reduction instead of
focusing on stopping
uh drug use completely focusing on how
to use
within uh with this uh to the least
amount of harm
to drugs to mothers who were using drugs
while pregnant
they basically had uh prepared a
pamphlet on how pregnant women
could use hard drugs more safely during
pregnancy now harm reduction has proven
to be effective in a lot of ways
but i felt like this was taking things a
little far if you're only
risking harm to yourself it's one thing
but when you add a child in i think it's
quite different
uh i feel like we should be telling
pregnant women don't use meth crack
heroin etc while pregnant as your baby
will be [ __ ] up
i feel like we should be able to just
tell people not to do things instead of
constantly trying to meet them where
they are
uh when their behavior is becoming more
and more extreme what's the
next painful you shouldn't molest your
kids but if you do here's how to
[ __ ] them up the least well if you've
got the printer why not
um if we keep moving the standard
further and further doesn't society just
self-destruct at some point
feel like san francisco is a good
example of a city gone too far left
and regular citizens suffering because
of it i'm curious about both of your
opinions on how we rain in our wokeness
before we start to feel so awake that
psychosis sits in
uh p.s neil has worn the bird noise
meditation headband
thing uh have you worn it on ayahuasca
if not i think it's a missed opportunity
yeah i haven't but i did it's
kind of rude um
my fitbit and my heart rate was
consistent
oh not through the roof no interesting
um yeah i don't uh
uh should you tell
this reminds me of your friend's book
yeah the assumption is
that people are going to do
just because you say don't doesn't
mean that they're gonna
listen to you so i think
it's this is a mitigating thing yeah i i
it's horrible and but if you're
i'm not saying give them crack i'm not
saying give them heroin i'm not saying
give them the
the um chemical i'm just saying
[Music]
it's better than abstinence that's
abstinence is no
sex education that's what that's what
he's kind of going like
should we be telling kids how to [ __ ]
right
what do you what are the options they're
[ __ ]
she's using i mean is there should you
get them into rehab
absolutely should you get them into a
program absolutely but
it's not a realistic approach because
it's like one how
you know we punish drug users they still
come in
you know because it's more than just
like oh you know that
i got that punishment worked it's like
that's an addiction it's a it's it's own
thing so
i'm not surprised that san francisco has
a harm reduction thing i think i don't
know i kind of don't think it's bad
it's just really sad and tricky it's
like a tree it's a
it's yeah but i don't think it's better
that's the that's the
yeah i don't i don't know obviously when
you put it into like molesting kids and
da da but
you can take that like you can take
new age help or different ways of
helping people
you can take out whatever the thing is
you're helping and put in something
worse
yeah and and it kind of ruins the whole
thing
but i yeah i it's also just abstinence
does not work it ends up a
they it makes it worse because people
feel like they're well yeah i'm already
[ __ ] why even wear a condom
you know what i mean like i'm already uh
breaking the rule so i it's good i might
as well go for broke
100 yeah and then like don't think of
what i mean it here is
if you just take out uh drug-addicted
pregnant mothers and you put in
child molesters like it's never going to
feel good yeah you know
um so you know it would feel pretty good
like wife peter you know be your wife
don't ruin the face
yeah so it's under the where people
can't see the marks right
so just you know yeah can you do
um yep uh
[Music]
goodbye now you've got mail hnf
and wbt about our treatment for
treatment resistant
depression uh after a
car accident over five years ago my
son's traumatic brain injury has led to
a deep and
treatment-resistant depression which is
common in tbi sufferers about 60 to 70
percent
since he's been since since he has tried
several medications ssris etc and
therapy
cbt and much better results with dbt
over the years uh with minor improvement
would your next stop be
tms ketamine psychedelics or ayahuasca
this is like a neil brennan game show
yeah really
um what should he do next
uh has tbi i'm sorry
his tbi has similar symptoms as seen in
the hbr real sports video you referenced
short-term and long-term memory loss
with depression about four years
after not even smoking pot before i
started micro dosing lsd
and found many benefits and decided to
have a full dose experiment
which has been key to improving all
aspects of my life
allowing us to move to san diego wow
well well moving on well well well
exodus my ass
people are out here doing lsd and
[ __ ] charging into
california uh i know you're not a doctor
you don't know that but we've been
through so many we feel we could benefit
from your firsthand experience
thanks so much for all the laughs and
insights feelers since day since episode
one really
um i would suggest
tms or ayahuasca those are the two
things that
tms had that's transcranial magnetic
stimulation
that's very helpful i've had it twice
and then i asked of course uh if you
want
to wear wristbands um
so uh so yeah like i think
i would ayahuasca recommend i would
recommend ios get it pretty much
everybody yeah
you know me yeah i'm the the star child
in fact
you wanna know what i did today told my
mom about it
you want her i don't want her to do it i
just wanted her to know
oh well how was she like oh no she was
it's a it's a long story but my sister
had a babysitter
who was that my mom and sister and uh
kids loved
and she moved and she's like
and she was brazilian and before she
moved she was like you know why you guys
like me
i do ayahuasca every weekend goodbye
goodbye so my mom's like what so
my mom has some experience with it
as like she called it a tea so why don't
you call it
which it is it is it's a cold brew tape
it's a hot tea that's called
iced tea it's an iced tea it's lipton's
it's basically lipton's um so she was
fine with it
and then i also threw in like there's
like the christian element to it that is
fake but funny
do you would you what if she was like no
neil this is wrong
she uh she wouldn't or what if she's the
funny thing
is i it it would not be in her best
interest because the reason i called her
was because it
the other night on ayahuasca i felt
connected to her really
yes so i was like calling her to tell
her like hey
i'm connected i felt very connected to
you
because of this tea so
you want to approve of this tea or not
it's a shakedown
um but she was she was with goodbye
you've got manual banks day one
rl stein and all that jazz uh i can't
believe this is my first email and feel
free not to read this on the air
uh uh the oh it's about mr potato head
okay uh the brand is changing its name
from mr potato head to just potato head
because they want it to be known they
sell more than just the mr potato
headline
they will still sell a mr and mrs potato
head figure
i'm just sick of my conservative friends
crying about cancer culture and the libs
and getting worked up over those things
that's another case where i didn't
i assumed i knew the story and just
didn't know what it was yeah we didn't
know that
yeah um um so but also
doesn't it seem a little late if it's
just marketing it's a br
they're just changing the name of the
company no no i know what i'm saying is
they introduced mrs potato it's a long
ago
i don't know just a funny move right now
they're just changing it it's like
instagram now is face instagram by
facebook
yeah it's it's nothing just so people
no but just so people know that they
sell mrs potato head it's just funny
no that wasn't why they changed it they
changed it just to potato head
meaning they sell it's they're probably
getting into like
potato babies and all that honestly like
they're gonna get into like
mashed potatoes they're gonna get all of
it they're grilled [ __ ]
sauteed rotten they'll get into they're
just going to expand the brand
that's how they're doing right so
that's a it's a that's a point against
the trans
goodbye you've got mail hey i love the
show blah blah i love bianca simply put
you're wrong about fat people
this is a good fat letter and it is
uh this the bmi on this letter pretty
this this uh this letter is morbidly
long um uh and uh
simply put you're wrong about fat people
their bmis and just about everything
regarding the subject
i am part of the small percentage of
women you described in your last show
who have a diagnosable
medical issue that puts me outside of
the normal bmi range
i have pcos a hormonal disease that
affects millions of women and it's hard
to diagnose
i'm not a huge person but if you don't
have skinny pcos your body is literally
fighting you to lose weight even if you
don't eat
but i swear uh but i can't wear a sign
for others to let them know i have a
disease before they judge me for someone
who struggled with depression i'm very
surprised that you would
simply view the typical fat person
someone who is simply not disciplined um
i understand that you have attempted to
clarify that it's just
fat people who don't have diagnosable
medical issues who should be ashamed but
their gluttony should not be written off
as laziness
you and i and millions of others who
battle clinical depression
she keeps bringing it up she's using it
against me
um know that finding treatments and
doctors that could help us is a constant
battle
being an alcoholic is a constant battle
having any mental health issues constant
battle
it's off-putting insensitive and
contradictory that you would judge an
invisible mental health issue
as something that you just have to work
at some more
um anyway i just wanted to write in for
your listeners who may have shed a tear
to when our issues are dismissed by
someone who we know is intelligent and
non-judgmental about so many other
subjects
um did i make you cry baby i'm kidding
well did i get to you okay uh you have
no clue why someone decides to eat their
seventh donut or yeah they do because
they're delicious
uh or why they would choose to ruin
their metabolism while falling into this
depressive episode
on and on and on she's basically just
crying for empathy which
you've come on the right day uh-oh here
we go i got empathy
um for uh my
my obese brothers and sisters daniel
hold on let me let me put this wristband
this put your in the air one time neal's
different now
um there's another fat letter uh
well it's funny k talnardo and bianco
caliente
hey uh active lstner neil i
don't think fatness is solvable with
shame or discipline if shame worked
there'd be no fat people
because fatness is super shameful if
discipline worked i wouldn't be heavy
because i am disciplined accomplished
accomplishment oriented [ __ ]
there's a strong vein of compulsion and
genetics at work plus the reality that
unlike alcohol or drugs food is
unavoidable
uh imagine if you walked into an a
meeting and told all the alcoholics they
would have to drink one beer at a time
for the rest of their lives
um okay uh i don't love the analogy but
uh just one beer right now how hard is
that
uh easy for you maybe and for me but not
for them
uh would it be fair to shame them and
lecture them about discipline when they
inevitably
whatever yes i have empathy for you
uh if you're overweight whether it is
what are the genetics here are my
empathy categories
okay no i have empathy for everybody
i don't believe you i do i i i
i'm sorry that you're caught up in it or
i'm sorry that you're caught up in that
habit or i'm sorry
that you have a genetic
disorder pcos or
you i'm sorry that you're caught up in
an unhealthy thing
it's a horrible podcast when you talk
like this
but it's so refreshing sorry guys
refreshing
empathy emily that's empathy for you i
i'm sorry that you're going through that
i'm gonna read this
go hi jesus
it's really loud hi neil hi binky
lst ner from madison wisconsin
that's nice hope to see neil in town in
the future i just
one warned okay i was just
warned and had my profile info deleted
from a popular dating app that just went
public for hate speech
in reality i just expressed a feelery
attitude that i'm not attracted to
overweight people
with the tag sorry not sorry
i think i'm being honest in an
environment that doesn't allow
discrimination for body type
in the search algorithm uh
what do you think we don't talk like
that no more you came on the wrong day
uh now i
i it's the obvious um
someone flipping comparison would be a
woman saying i need a tall guy
uh or no shorties or whatever that's
like
right they don't say it they just live
it yeah
um so just don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can just
hit x instead of like [ __ ] you right
sound
i mean definitely don't uh do it like
say
not as i do don't do it i would never
write no fatties on the
thing you would just all right you got
to have giant cans
but i would never respawn never mind it
doesn't matter go ahead
um yeah just don't don't write that
you're being an [ __ ]
it's not you're not it's not helpful um
whereas me i use it as it's like a
philosophical argument i'm having
you're sir you're dealing at a low
frequency i'm at a high frequency
i wear wristbands uh goodbye
uh again star child
feel free to start you've got hello neil
and banks yeah i'm sorry beale and nyx
on the last episode while neil was
making a very valid point about blues
music he briefly alluded to the blues
brothers movie and i wanted
him to dig into that a little more i'm a
44 year old
long time fan of comedy and i'm
admittedly a few years shy
of the era of early snl and the blues
brothers initial relevance that said
there's plenty of stuff from that era
that i love and admire however i've
literally never gotten the blues
brothers appeal and to a lesser extent
john belushi the blues brothers in
particular
is painfully unfunny to me like what is
it even about
some losers from chicago that sing
motown cover songs and get in car chase
a lot
i can watch some [ __ ] like home
improvement and while it's not my cup of
tea i can see why some people might like
it
but with the blues brothers it still
baffles me
uh now i i know how people are about
their dead icons so whatever
i bring so whenever i bring this up it's
met with at best a lukewarm response
people saying
what basically sums up to you had to be
there because apparently john belushi
was some comedic genius but man
i don't see it rest in power king though
of course i realize that this is all
opinion and personal taste but i'm
curious what neil's taking the blues
brothers and belushi is
after all you're a pro and a grizzled
veteran at this humor [ __ ]
not humor it's more comedy humor is like
uh less funny
um so maybe you have some insight us
layman don't
with things like this perhaps you can
explain a new one so missing here how
neil feel and what binks
think because people hated my blues
point of view
i didn't like it well well i said it i
said i did it but like people like
[ __ ]
you know oh they're like yeah
it's fine we're all gonna be fine it's
like i it's like
there's another one coming next week
fellas yeah it's just you know um
it's not gonna affect the blues at all
um it's still
like jazz it's still basically it still
basically
has to be supported by charitable
foundations so you know what's good
enough about jazz um uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
to polarize people further uh belushi
i actually told lauren i didn't think
belushi was funny
he just did not do it for me okay i
didn't say it like hey man
i basically said what this guy's saying
like i watch belushi and
it doesn't work on me it's
farley to me is uh
way sillier i'm way i'm very aware of
farley's like silliness yeah and
that farley farley's also i think fatter
so seeing him to a cartwheel
feels like an optical illusion or
something like how the [ __ ] are you
doing that
with belushi he just seems like not
fat enough to be like pure a pure fat
guy yeah
and um though i do have empathy forms
gotta say it must be said uh and the
blues brothers
are they're [ __ ] in the blues brothers
there's
like good jokes in the blues brothers
like giving their address as wrigley
field is a good joke
like there's nazis after them that's
funny
and but it's mostly just minstrel
smith's real straight up there's no
other way
to call it it's just taking a black
thing and white people doing it
i didn't even realize that the joke in
the church is about black church
there's a joke where they're at church
and then people start doing flips
and like two years ago i was like wait a
minute
that seems like a joke about how good
black church is
uh so you're not wrong king
and uh john belushi not funny
but even like he did a
the samurai was like a one it was like
look at this white guy
doing a japanese guy he was just like
the
he capitalized on that kind of like yeah
but he did it at like a higher
intellectual level
right uh but it never
i get that he's a dynamic performer i
get that like
talking with a scratchy voice and
screaming blue's brother i remember the
joke in the blues brothers where he eats
there's a joke where he's like quick
impression and he eats a bunch of stuff
and he goes what am i and they go what
and he pops his and he goes is zit
and i was nine and thought that's a bad
joke
people 19 it's the most successful
already comedy of all time right
literally it's the most profitable movie
of all time and i thought that's not a
good joke
i don't [ __ ] know it doesn't mean it
doesn't mean i was wrong it's a popular
joke but in terms of like
what's the premise you feel your i mean
honestly i was like
i don't i don't know
house what did i say oh yeah it's an
animal house
will wow will really just come
bringing the hammer down bring the
hammer down gunning for your spot on the
job
animal house you know what's a good joke
an animal has that date rape one
that's a great hell of a joke i missed
all this kind of wow
bianca honey you got to go back um
they're animal houses got funny [ __ ]
they have one point of guys playing
acoustic guitar
in on like the steps and like it's like
just
like [ __ ] about guys who play custom
card parties and belushi
just smashes his guitar which is [ __ ]
hilarious
and the guys who wrote it are uh doug
kenny and and um
and i believe harold ramis who were
great i do like those old school
comedies that
are funny signs of the times like i'm
gonna get you sucka or
these things where you do get this
you know i don't know certain tropes
that
aren't i don't know that have been done
to death already but it was kind of the
first time they were
being rock had a good i'm gonna get you
soccer story the other day oh my god
i'd love i'm gonna get you sucker that
he we were talking he bit you know that
one rib joke
yeah he did it in his act
and he was doing it in his act and then
keenan wrote it into the script and
eddie was like you know that's rock's
joke
so they he's the only person in the
movie that they
flew out to be in the movie everybody
else was local
but keenan was like i get i don't know
if that he made him fly him out
but he's like you can't do that joke
somebody else can't do that joke
no i don't know if keenan knew chris did
the joke i would confuse you there is
like okay we have it's like smells like
a paco
delicious there's a person named keenan
in the story
it sounds like i fell down and hit my
head
and and uh flip mode is the greatest
yes it's a we have what we have here is
a uh
a case of paco deliciousness and a cute
case of the paco deliciousness
goodbye greetings neil and always on cue
will
i don't know about always but oh here's
a great one one okay this is about
potato head
i should have put it with the other
potato head transgender ls listener here
now i could be wrong by but my
understanding was the mr potato head
company
uh under hasbro is is dropping the
mister from the company name
uh the toys being sold are still mr and
misses there
is going to be a new family set that is
not gendered do i give a [ __ ] no
did some reporter hit the jackpot to get
paid views
bet your ass they did is going to the
bathroom a nightmare
this is great all of our questions
answered yes perfect sometimes
it also does not help that a common
medication to block testosterone
prescribed for transgender women
is a diuretic yeah so do i hold it till
i get home uh
chance someone looking for a fight or
end up being chased out on camera
that sounds like a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah uh in your words as someone that
does not
visib visually read as a woman you
[ __ ] up somehow
that's what they're just not saying
she's saying as that person you [ __ ]
up
uh that's a very common sentiment by
women within the trans community
my makeup wasn't good enough or i needed
more surgery
to pass as a cis woman uh can i even
afford it
uh do i even want to pass assists uh
these are thoughts that practically
never leave my mind
uh then we will get attacked by someone
misusing feminism to say we're
practicing an outdated ultra feminine
lifestyle
to hold back other women from equal
rights or hijacking safe spaces
just can't win some days is gender a
thing going away
no the concept of uh organization
paperwork great i love paperwork i
[ __ ] hate it
a few more form options to fill out
would be
helpful especially for non-binary
individuals uh the majority of people
will skip those questions anyway since
it's not relevant for them
bianca you would just ask quote what are
your pronouns without
uh preferred in the questions okay or
like most of the time we will correct
you
on what to use if we feel uh it won't
start a whole rant
from who we're talking to uh we are a
tiny bit of the population and we
disagree with each other
on a lot of the concepts being debated
by cisgender folks who don't bother
asking for our input
well why would we um if interested there
are a bunch of transgender
transgender subreddits one could ask
questions and to educate themselves
people there will do a much better job
than this non-run-on mess i wrote to the
trans guys
and non-binary pals who are never uh
brought into these talking points stay
strong fam love you
and i when i read this first time i
didn't realize it was a dick they end
with tell dave i say oh yeah
you didn't realize that i didn't real i
was like
why why are you bringing neal for first
thought
i'll fight you um i
love this person it is very helpful
somebody else wrote on my twitter like
that they're like you're going to get
the you sounded awful talking about
the tran it's like you and i were both i
think
pretty open about not knowing oh yeah we
even said it could
elicit someone like i wish there were
like this is very [ __ ] helpful
it's helpful and it's nice to be able to
just get a glimpse
it's not like i need to walk in your
shoes but it's nice that they
allowed us to come in to what it is like
there like the bathroom thing thinking
about that
thinking about that's where i get like
that's makes me want to cry three
percent
do you know what i mean like again this
is this is the wristband talking
but but it's like oh [ __ ] there must be
and your diuretic and yeah and the thing
and a chain reaction
just things you didn't think about like
do i even want to pass assist that's
really interesting
you know i think like i don't know a
long time ago
on the podcast i clumsily stumbled
through
something i was trying to say and i
couldn't figure out the right way to say
it but i was saying something like
my point was and it wasn't well put but
it was that why do sometimes it seems
like transgender women want that kind of
what she tapped on like practicing an
outdated ultra feminism sort of thing
like i do wonder why
like what type of like how do you go
about saying oh i want to be this kind
of woman because there's so many
different types of women you know
we're not like monolithic so i was
kind of wondering about that when she
says you know do i even want to pass a
sis like
that's really interesting it's
interesting that
these different things that you i think
you
just naively assume yeah they want to be
exactly like
me as a woman someone that's
transitioning to a woman to the joke
about that
where he said uh the
most transgender people only this is
it's a ten-year-old joke but he they
only want to
uh dress like a woman from the far side
cartoon
like just this like crazy specific
crazy good specific uh
angle where you don't yeah it's like why
are you all drawn to that
thing um but then i start realizing
but they're not all drawn they're not
and you start realizing you've put in
you filled in a lot of the blanks for
trans people
your own blanks where i don't know i'm
just happy
someone wrote it yeah somebody that was
uh measured about it
and gave us the benefit of the doubt
that we're not we don't want to
do them harm right and at least i don't
i can't speak for you
uh and this is it reminds me of
she brought dave up the the
segment that we used to do again coming
full circle with mooney on the show
ask a black dude was based on dave had
done it at a stand-up show
where he was like it was all wiping i
was like you guys have any questions
about blackness do you want me to answer
i'll just
and one of the que this is a [ __ ]
hilarious question that somebody asked
this in new york in the 90s uh or 2000s
they go hey why do black guys
wear one of their pant legs up
when they ride bikes which what
and it it's because they didn't want to
get yeah oil on their
on their temps i'm kidding they don't
want to get oil on their uh jeans
whatever but
there was a but it was a thing that what
there are a million questions
about transgender people that uh are not
coming from a bad place
that i i wish that there were more
uh there was more of a community i think
she said uh he
she said subreddit i don't think i'm
gonna go there there is a community we
just aren't
more of a more of a i'm sorry i don't
mean like there's not a community i mean
a dialogue
i wish there was two i mean that's the
reason like why we talk i mean what do
we say a race and dating advice podcast
and that's the and the aggravating thing
is
um that if you
don't know it's automatically
uh hostile you don't know because you
don't no i don't [ __ ] know it's like
the thing i said word
where i was like what somebody said
what's their
uh anatomy like and i was like i don't
know and we're liberals
right so imagine what my mom thinks
terrified
not with the ayahuasca stuff but now
that no or whatever an older person
thinks but that's everybody i mean i
i told you a story about i my friend let
off balloons for her birthday
and these people tried these
environmentalists right to fight us
and i was gonna was gonna i was gonna
yeah but uh violence with the
environment and the thing of like
it's not my job to teach you yeah it is
because i don't
you're in it's it's what we're talking
about with like civil rights
shouldn't have to yeah you shouldn't
have to
but unfortunately you're dealing with
human beings
and there's a lot of it's remedial our
understanding of [ __ ] is remedial
i i i think there's a limit for what
someone
because i remember i was watching
something and they were talking about it
was a trans woman talking about
the surgery she had to have a
like for her genitalia and i just
googled it
and it was all there you know so is it a
trans woman's job to educate me
i can also just go get the education
yeah but you're gonna get a to your
point last week you're gonna get a
better education from her
i am but there also is the point of
invasiveness especially when it comes to
trans topics like
what's it like down there them you know
obviously we're not going to be that
crass but there is but we all
are at some point someone wants to ask
them something i mean i can just
you can get the information do you need
it always from the horse's mouth
do you need a black person to tell you
like that's racist
or no but there are
[Music]
there are i remember we were doing a
sketch
we did a sketch that didn't work
and it was a where me and dave both it
was about
how faulty the uh
descript police description like artist
rendering system was
where we both described we both picked a
celebrity and then had them
and tried to describe them to an artist
to a school like you actually did to a
real one
yeah we got we hired a sketch artist and
like tried to why didn't the sketch work
because it was uh it was
it wasn't that it was it wasn't a sketch
it was literally it was just interesting
described martin luther king and i
described gary coleman
and did they look like it do you have
the photos
i have no idea but in
i just remembered in the sketch dave
said something maybe it was a he's like
he was talking about
black skin
black men's penises are darker than the
rest of their body
i had no idea about that i had
when i tell you none
none it wasn't i didn't ask
i'm happy to know it like oh i'm like
that's interesting but i wasn't like
it's exotic and did it i didn't
immediately go to like a bad faith thing
okay and so i feel like if there's more
good faith uh explanations of things
that are like oh that's interesting i
don't know that
it's better for society yeah and there
are a lot of
uh white and blac and non-black people
right now going like i didn't know that
goodbye for help we're helping we're
helping everyone
um do you have can we just do the last
one yeah we're just gonna do that
um you've got mail oh this is very funny
uh hey what's up neil bianca this is
slim
uh love the show and the i don't know if
that's an eminem joke
um or the comedian you know islam
no black jesus did his name
no he don't like me oh really no
what'd you do nothing it's a his name's
not slim i mean are you
is that his real name google
uh i'm pretty sure his name's slim
gerald johnson well slim oh slink
slink okay my bad still don't like me
he just i just there's a there's a seek
there's a
cut there's a there's a quadrant of
black people that think i'm a [ __ ]
and i have to live with that okay
because they just because of press
when dave said that something racist
happened people think i'm the
white guy who laughed at him which is
why i said at the mark twain thing we
were like
oh cause they realized it wasn't me
right
but why change why update your files
you're the you're the queen
yeah just she she was he wasn't the
racist one yeah
um i just ran the organization
or whatever that is uh what's up neil
and bianca this is slim
love the show and the old podcast and i
got a question for both y'all neil has
anybody told you you remind them of
bobby that plays a ci agent on snowfall
and would you jump into a serious role
but with comedic element in that realm
like rock and fargo
uh that's the first question um
i'll explain what's racist about that
bianca all right don't get mad but do
you have allergies
i be hearing you sniffle on the audio
and i ain't want to assume the worst
wow or that you be in that joint party
in which
[ __ ] live your life if you are and can
you sing
you seem like you'd have a great singing
voice keep that [ __ ] player like y'all
do
um slim you answer yours first
um what happens with
um when you're affiliated with
black people the way i have been
okay people only assume
people think i look like eminem i don't
really look at them
people think i look like uh
uh there's just they once they associate
you with
that thing in your in their mind
that's who you are i can't really
explain it
um i don't not look like that guy that i
look like that guy
that one i look like him you know
yeah i'll give him that but it's always
like a black show
um i can't think of any examples but
that it's a
common thing where they're like you look
like and i'm like no
but you know cool uh and then of course
would i do drama you must not have seen
the
tom hardy hit capone last year where i
played his lawyer and i had
13 lines and was that bad you're good
thank you
um so i we've determined
long ago that i'm slightly allergic to
keith so i get sniffles when i'm in
heels up but i'm trying but she parties
i i feel bad i'm sorry you guys it's
annoying i don't
notice i do it do you notice i sniffle i
don't
do you will oh you will just shoot you
said yes
so he has to edit it oh yeah well that's
why well i will um
i think it's wrong that he puts reverb
on all of them
but that's his choice um i will
uh be i'll monitor my sniffles i'm sorry
i feel bad can you sing here's the funny
part about that
i i don't think you can okay relax
um i feel like i've maybe heard you
saying and it wasn't
as pretty as i thought it would be no no
no that
that definitely you made that up because
i definitely can't sing and it's
it would never have given you hope it's
never like it was not
no no no that's what i'm saying it
wasn't like you went for it
anyone that can see at a certain point
they're gonna break it up pretty quick
well also whatever i've sung i sing
bad like even worse than i can so it's
like
yeah bad or just a dog
just a wolf um but this is the weird
thing
all my life i have been asked
if i can sing specifically all the time
you have a voice like a singer do you
sing oh that's true well you do have a
deep voice i have a deep voice
voice and if you think about it like
whitney mariah all of them have
low does whitney have a low voice yeah
um they all have very yes i like
obsessed with whitney they all have very
low kind of gravely
voices so on bobby and christina she um
bobby whitney she had a low voice like
just walking around
uh yet she just has a low voice okay
never heard her speak no i did i just
thought i always
when i think of crack as whack i just
think like i don't hear it
deep um yeah i'm sure she has moments of
not being that's her just like me i
i talk like but no she has a no
neil i mean will go to the vault well
go to the e.t vault go to her it's not
fallen
no go to wendy williams or not wendy
her diane sawyer whitney and diane sayer
if that
wanted to be there to make sure you know
everything was cool and
that you know no other women were around
this is my first i i don't consider that
deep oh i do
it's like gravelly it's more like all
right what are you doing what do you
play that again love remember
i had never really ever been in love
with anybody like one of the women
that's a little something it's like a
little bit of a little
that's what i mean everybody it's like a
gravelly kind of quick impression
[Music]
um so yeah it's weird i kill it at
karaoke and i don't know why
interesting i kill it what's your song
um multiple so
i love a good um what's her name i love
a good paulab duel
um uh what's the last thing i think a
little river band
uh
i think a lot of old music no one
remembers but
um i'd pick rap songs with the n word in
it and say
i only say the animals
have you done karaoke no uh come on
maybe once no i don't even
my experience with karaoke is it's a
joke that gets
old quickly and you've got three minutes
and
15 seconds left after the joke is
already
uh done the worst is when you pick the
it sounds like a great song in your head
yep aka love shaq don't sing
the amount of and what
i was like [ __ ] going down in flames
left
uh there's an atlantic
harper's weekly harper's monthly
magazine
had a story 20 man 15 years ago
uh you know who loved ironically enough
whitney houston
and the song love jack who osama bin
laden
no specifically was gonna
kill bobby brown because he loved
whitney houston that was very racist
how to accept her osama bin binky
i don't know what that means osama bin
laden i just mean like i like love shaq
and whitney
yeah oh though
uh thank you um
uh that didn't he have a whole thing of
uh
what's her face porn black woman that
could speak russian
oh that one condi condoleezza right he
liked her
yeah didn't he have like photos of her
osama wanted to marry whitney houston
that is so funny uh
from 2012 i plan to kidnap whitney
houston
and was gonna had to wanted to kill
bobby brown
um that's [ __ ] weird i said i want to
[ __ ] her
that is a direct quote from osama bin
laden
guys you got a lot of look if you come
guys a lot of content for if you like
comedy information
clips insider knowledge
racial uh insights transgender insights
now
uh keenan potato inside
two different canons two different
canons multiple moonies
what a show so many many many now
unfortunately
for you we don't have to take this [ __ ]
you really don't
i don't know
you tell me
[Music]
[Music]